einen schönen guten tag und wir kommen
zu heute live wie geht es weiter mit der
impfkampagne in deutschland und wie
kommt vor allem endlich mehr tempo in
diese kampagne das sind die fragen mit
denen wir uns heute beschäftigen wollen
wir warten natürlich auf die
bundeskanzlerin die sich äußern wird
nach dem bund länder treffen heute das
kann noch dauern
wir wissen aber wie wir diese zeit
überbrücken können denn wir sprechen mit
frau professor marilyn abo oder abo sie
ist infektiologen forscht unter anderem
am deutschen zentrum für
infektionsforschung in hamburg zum
corona virus unter sehe ich hier auch
schon hinter mir
einen schönen guten tag frau so schön
dass sie bei uns sind ja die woche war
turbulent
es ging unter anderem darum dass der
impfstoff von astrazeneca ausgesetzt
wurde zunächst für drei tage dann wieder
verimpft werden darf seit heute wie
haben sie diesen vorgang bewertet schon
sagen eine harte woche oder eine
ansteigende woche für das ganze thema
impfen
ich denke das war ein wichtiges zeichen
wie das aufgearbeitet wurde
es ist ja auch relativ rasch gegangen
montag wurden die impfungen ausgesetzt
und heute kam schon das signal oder auch
gestern schon von der ehemann das signal
das ist gut aufgearbeitet wurde und das
ist jetzt weitergehen kann
hätten sie denn die impfung ausgesetzt
also mit diesem wirkstoff haben wir die
info in hamburg auf sein ob sie ist wenn
sie es zu entscheiden gehabt hätten wenn
sie der bundesgesundheitsminister
gewesen wären hätten sie dann aus gesagt
okay nach der empfehlung dann setze ich
das erstmal aus das ist ja umstritten
deswegen frage ich diskussion die auch
noch mal geführt werden kann aber ich
denke wir hatten hier in deutschland
eine häufung von
neben thrombosen die über dem
hintergrund in der bevölkerung lag und
es ist glaube ich auch wichtig für das
vertrauen in der bevölkerung dass wir
uns diesen signalen ganz ernsthaft
nachgehen insofern kann ich diese
entscheidung nachvollziehen da muss man
natürlich immer abwägen
gegenüber dem was verloren gehen kann
wenn man nicht stimmt also der das ist
ein risiko nutzen
diese entscheidung wurde in dieser art
und weise gefällt und jetzt müssen wir
gucken dass wir jetzt nach der freigabe
mit den auflagen und mit den
empfehlungen jetzt wieder schwung
aufnehmen ja über dieses
spannungsverhältnis nutzen und risiken
des impfstoffs gerade von auch
astrazeneca werden wir gleich noch mal
sprechen wollen aber vorher auch noch
mal gucken auf die ereignisse des tages
wie gesagt wir warten auf die
pressekonferenz das wird noch ein
weilchen dauern so wie wir die sache
einschätzen wollen aber gucken was heute
im laufe des tages vielleicht schon
durchgesickert ist an information bzw
einschätzungen ein beitrag von meiner
kollegin andrea mauch dazu dass dieser
72 jährige mann seinen regulären
impftermin mit astrazeneca wahrnehmen
kann ist heute auch eine politische
botschaft der mann ist winfried
kretschmann ministerpräsident von baden
württemberg
im anschluss an die impfung wird er als
länderchef am virtuellen impfgipfel mit
der kanzlerin teilnehmen die botschaft
die im kampagne läuft nach drei tagen
impfstoff wird wieder mit astrazeneca
geimpft von verunsicherung des
erleichterung die reaktionen heute in
deutschen impfzentren
wie weit sich das netzwerk wird sie im
gespräch zeigen ich bin überglücklich
und dankbar von ganzem herzen dass ich
jetzt diesen fdp habe ich bin sehr
glücklich sehr glücklich
in der beschlussvorlage zum impfgipfel
heute ist von zusätzlich 4 millionen
bayern tech dosen an die eu die rede von
denen 580.000 dosen oft deutschland
entfallen diese sollen insbesondere für
hot spots und zur abwehr von virus
mutanten eingesetzt werden heißt es
auch die hausärzte sollen nun
großflächig in die impfungen einbezogen
werden nach ostern soll es losgehen
der gesundheitsminister warnt vor zu
großen erwartungen
mit den mengen die wir in den ersten
aprilwochen das wird sich im mai stand
heute schon ändern können aber den
ersten aprilwochen erwarten wird es
beginnen können inhouse in arztpraxen
haushalts praxen erstmal mit etwa
umgerechnet einen sprechstunde pro woche
mehrere ministerpräsidenten wollen sich
beim impfgipfel heute auch für den
russischen impfstoff sputnik wie stark
machen
der befindet sich im europäischen
zulassungsverfahren wurde aber noch
nicht bestellt die datenlage müsse
geklärt werden sagt jens spahn genauso
mengen und verfügbarkeiten wenn über
diese fragen klarheit es lassen sich
auch verträge schließen und ich bin
tatsächlich sehr dafür wenn die
europäische union jetzt nicht da auch
was macht dass wir jetzt ein national
machen
an ihrem ziel im sommer allen
bürgerinnen und bürgern ein impfangebot
zu machen will die kanzlerin festhalten
im anschluss an den impf gepäck tritt
sie vor die presse also das sind jetzt
einige aspekte natürlich angesprochen
worden in diesem beitrag
frau professor oder ich würde trotzdem
gerne nochmal bei astrazeneca bleiben am
anfang
es ist über die gefährlichkeit
gesprochen worden wie bewerten sie die
also die gefährlichkeit muss man sagen
anführungszeichen denn das ist ja in der
tat noch die frage wie hoch schätzen sie
diese gefährlichkeit ein und vor allem
für wen besteht da ein erhöhtes risiko
es sind natürlich ganz wichtige fragen
die in denen noch weitere aufarbeitung
folgen wird es handelt sich ja um
häufungen von fällen von sinus
venenthrombosen das ist eine sehr
seltene komplikation die jetzt gefunden
wurde in deutschland waren dass er über
13 fälle in der mehrheit waren dass
junge frauen oder frauen unter 55 und
auch ein mann und es gab auch todesfälle
dabei es ist momentan ja noch nicht
letztendlich geklärt ob es sichtlich mit
der im punkt zu tun hat aber man muss
natürlich dadurch dass es in einer
zeitlichen assoziationen mit dem stoff
aufgetreten ist muss man das natürlich
weiter verfolgen und muss auch dann
jetzt in der folge darüber aufklären
also insofern als ältere männer
das ist sicherlich eine ganz andere da
ist gar keine frage aber man muss
natürlich eine jüngere frauen über und
die erste müssen aufklären über dieses
risiko ein ganz ganz verhältnis risiko
und dann ist ja die bewertung so
dahingehend das risiko nutzen verhältnis
auf jeden fall auf der der nutzen seite
steht
was halt an infektionen verhindert
werden kann durch die impfung im
gegensatz zu den risiken den sehr
seltenen risiken die jetzt beschrieben
wurden
ich würde gerne unseren zuschauern und
usern noch ein paar weitere
informationen zu astrazeneca mit an die
hand geben darüber wo wir jetzt auch
gerade eben stehen was diesen impfstoff
angeht was gefährlichkeit an ge
beziehungsweise was die risiken sind
meine kollegin nina niebergall hat sich
auch mit diesem impfstoff noch mal etwas
genauer befasst astrazeneca sei ein
sicherer und wirksamer impfstoff so die
einschätzung der europäischen
arzneimittelagentur gestern
trotzdem soll es einen bahn hinweis
geben der zusammenhang zwischen dem
impfstoff und den seltenen hirn
venenthrombosen nach wie vor nicht
ausgeschlossen
knapp 1,8 millionen mal wurde der astra
zeneca impfstoff in deutschland kämpft
bei 13 menschen wurde danach eine hirn
venenthrombose diagnostiziert zwölf
davon frauen
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass es geimpfte
trifft liegt bei etwa 1 zu 140 1000
wahr ist aber auch bei diesen sehr
seltenen thrombosen während von 1,8
millionen einwohner innen eigentlich
fünf bis neun fälle zu erwarten pro jahr
unter den astra zeneca geimpften sind es
schon 13
in gerade mal fünf wochen was passiert
da im gehirn das blut verklumpt in den
venen bei frauen dreimal häufiger als
bei männern
das größte risiko haben jüngere um die
30 die symptome starke kopfschmerzen
krampfanfälle sehstörungen frühzeitig
erkannt lässt sich die thrombose gut
behandeln
im schlimmsten fall aber führt sie zu
schlaganfällen die tödlich enden können
frau professor ado also wenn wir jetzt
über risiken von astrazeneca sprechen
dann habe ich jetzt aus diesem beitrag
gelernt dass es da in der tat vor allem
um risiken geht für weibliche patienten
aber auch noch in einem gewissen alter
unter 55 können sie das so in etwa
bestätigen
ihr habt ganz genauso sieht die
datenlage derzeit aus und welche
möglichkeiten oder bzw was würden sie
denn frauen in der altersgruppe raten
also die sollten sich dann nach
möglichkeit mit astrazeneca nicht impfen
lassen
ja ich denke das ist halt so zu fünft zu
früh so ein statement zu machen wir
wissen dass wir müssen sie darüber
aufklären dass in einem das in einer
ganz seltenen nebenwirkungen selten eine
häufung diese erscheinung dieses
ereignis auftreten kann und dann muss
man diese person oder die geimpfte zu
impfen die personen das mit das risiko
den nutzen mit dem arzt als
ausdiskutieren also es ist wie gesagt
das ist ganz klar dass wir in der
älteren bevölkerung ist das risiko an
krebs zu erkranken oder auch erschwerend
belauscht zu haben oder auch zu
versterben sehr hoch es ist natürlich
eine 20-jährige frau etwas anders
insgesamt müssen wir ist es nämlich
wichtig dass wir die impfkampagne mit
den vier zugelassenen impfstoffen in
deutschland weiter vorantreiben
und da brauchen wir natürlich auch eine
bessere verfügbarkeit von den
impfstoffen wenn es möglich ist auf
einen anderen impfstoff auszuweichen
wäre das natürlich eine möglichkeit wird
diese frauen in frankreich da gibt es
überlegungen beziehungsweise das ist
auch schon konkret dass menschen über 55
also beziehungsweise nur noch menschen
über 55 eben mit diesen impfstoff
geimpft werden halten sie das für
sinnvoll wenn das möglich wäre also ich
glaube wir müssen diese strategien jetzt
auch wenn weitere daten gesammelt werden
und auch wenn wir einen besseren
überblick über die verfügbarkeit der
impfstoffe haben halt dann nochmal
evaluieren
das ist glaube ich haben wir jetzt die
gute situation dass wir jetzt mal
weitermachen können aber das wäre
natürlich ein mögliches szenario
entweder jüngere frauen die halt in
dieser risikogruppe fallen wo man auch
immer wieder sagen muss es eine sehr
sehr seltenes risiko dass man die
gegebenenfalls mit anderen impfstoffen
impft oder halt die impfstoffe in andere
altersgruppen verschiebt aber das ist
eine sehr komplizierte diskussion die
vorsichtig geführt werden muss und
momentan sollte man mitnehmen dass eine
empfehlung eine positive nutzen
risikobewertung für diesen stoff für
astrazeneca und alle anderen impfstoffe
besteht und dass wir in dieser art und
weise weiter impfen sollten
das ist also auch noch mal klar
festzuhalten es besteht momentan die
empfehlung und eben eine positive
einschätzung
ganz wichtig weil ihm und fragt uns über
youtube wir nehmen wir auch immer gerne
unsere user mit an der stelle auch noch
einmal die herausforderung an euch gerne
wieder mitzumachen mit fragen und
kommentaren leiden und schreibt konnte
zwischen den sinus venenthrombosen und
der anti baby pille ein zusammenhang
gefunden werden
ja diese untersuchungen laufen noch sind
jetzt zum teil auch personen gewesen die
jetzt keine konzepte nicht mehr im alter
mann für konzeption das wird momentan
noch erarbeitet nein also dass diese
frage kommt natürlich weil ja auch bei
der aufklärung für die anti-baby-pille
auch darauf hingewiesen wird dass mehr
thrombotische ereignisse vorkommen
können dass man deswegen auch nicht
rauchen soll also das sind natürlich zu
wenige fälle um auch diese assoziation
zu machen das sind ja jetzt in
deutschland 13
über 13 fälle pauli fans über facebook
kann man nichts vorbeugend machen wenn
man gegebenenfalls zur betroffenen
personen gruppe gehört die gefährdet ist
zb eben für thrombosen
ja das ist auch schon oft gefragt worden
ob man eine aspirin nehmen kann oder
irgendeiner weise heparin spritzen
das ist derzeit nicht empfohlen also es
ist momentan empfohlen wenn man solche
symptome 4 bis 16 tage nach der impfung
hat dann sollte man sich frühzeitig in
ärztliche behandlung begeben um
gegebenenfalls eine solche diagnose früh
zu erkennen dann kann man es auch gut
behandeln wie gesagt ganz eine seltene 1
zu 1 6 millionen
das ist eine sehr seltene nebenwirkung
dennoch müssen wir dafür sensibilisieren
darüber aufklären und informieren
dann würde ich gerne noch an der stelle
jörg wunderlich mitnehmen der sagt über
facebook kann frau also etwas zur brust
der impfungen mit biontech sagen nachdem
man mit astrazeneca geimpft wurde also
kann sozusagen können die impfstoffe
miteinander kombiniert werden
er ist eine total interessante frage
da laufen irgendwann ganz große studien
zu das prinzip nennt sich mix and match
also tatsächlich kann es sein dass in
der zukunft ist nicht nur aus dieser
situation heraus sondern das war ja
schon vorher
seit januar laufen diese studien schon
und zwar kombiniert man da eben stoffe
miteinander und es laufen studien wo man
zuerst mit astrazeneca impfen damit bei
antec oder zuerst mit bayern keck und
damit als basilika also diese
kombination von impfstoffen wird
vielleicht auch eine strategie der
zukunft sein
dazu läuft gibt es momentan noch keine
studiendaten aber diese schule laufen
schon seit zwei monaten
wir haben heute auch schon also wie
sowieso in den letzten tagen natürlich
häufiger den bundesgesundheitsminister
gehört jan sparen ganz wichtig auch an
der stelle dass er sich eben für ein
europäisches vorgehen auch noch mal
ausgesprochen hat beziehungsweise auch
nochmal informationen darüber gegeben
hat wie momentan
die verzahnung auf europäischer ebene
läuft das wollen wir uns gerade auch
nochmal anhören
wir haben uns gestern nachmittag
abgestimmt habe ich mich mit
europäischen partnerländern auch
frankreich italien niederlande gehen ja
in ähnlichen weg wie wir und ich habe
mir natürlich abgestimmt mit den
gesundheitsministerin und
gesundheitsminister der bundesländer so
dass dieses vorgehen auf basis auch der
empfehlung der europäischen
arzneimittelagentur sicher und wirksam
wichtig aber eben ein zusätzlicher
hinweis in der fach und
patienteninformation dass diese
entscheidung breit fachlich und
politisch mitgetragen wird
und ich bin froh darüber dass am ende
die gesundheitsminister meinem vorschlag
gefolgt sind schon heute auch wieder mit
den impfungen zu beginnen also
vielleicht dazu auch noch mal der
hinweis dass frankreich ja doch ein
bisschen anders vorgeht werten für ihn
schon angesprochen eben auch mit dem
mittel überlegungen nur noch über
55-jährige mit astrazeneca zu impfen
wie bewerten sie denn stand jetzt muss
man ja sagen also die entscheidung das
impfen jetzt in deutschland ohne jede
einschränkung wieder aufzunehmen
das haben wir auch immer
betont das sind ja freiwillige impfungen
und welche welche strategie die richtige
ist das kann man ja noch momentan nicht
abschließend bewerten also ich denke es
ist eine richtige entscheidung dass
deshalb haben wir jetzt auch schon
mehrfach gehört dass die risiko nutzen
abwägung bewertet wird von der whu von
der emo von der stiko dass wir pro
impfen in den altersgruppen mit
aufklärung und information dass das die
richtige strategie ist
wir müssen das natürlich jetzt weiter
beobachten das sind ja häufungen die ja
ganz neu sind also es ist ein bisschen
so wie es in der pandemie bisher immer
gewesen ist wir lernen ja über diese
zustände diese diese auf vorkommnisse
jetzt gerade immer noch dazu und
vielleicht müssen wir auch nochmal
später die strategie anpassen ich denke
die entscheidung wie sie jetzt getroffen
wurde ist die richtige und es wird ja
sehr engmaschig begleitet vielleicht
noch also ganz zum abschluss sozusagen
dieses astrazeneca themenkomplexes noch
mal die frage an die leute die jetzt
damit geimpft worden sind was sollten
sie beachten auf welche sozusagen
anzeichen oder so sollten die bei sich
achten in den tagen danach
also man sagt ja dass man halt ab dass
diese häufung von takt 4 bis 16
aufgetreten sind also was ist so neu
auftretenden symptome es kommt ja nach
der impfung oft also an tag 1 23 zu
kopfschmerzen fieber das ist ganz normal
falls es nach tag 4 noch zu neu
auftretende kopfschmerzen schwindel zu
übelkeit zu hautveränderung also
einblutungen in die haut kommen sollte
da sollte man sehr zügig nach mit diesen
symptomen einen arzt aufsuchen um das
abklären zu lassen wie gesagt eine sehr
seltene nebenwirkung und aber das sind
die symptome auf die man achten sollte
ich gucke parallel immer so ein bisschen
auf das bild im kanzleramt
beziehungsweise wo daneben auch die
kanzlerin erwartet wird beim bund länder
treffen da sehen wir es auch gerade aber
da ist eben noch nichts zu sehen
ich bin sehr dankbar dafür dass frau
professor wo sich die zeit nimmt und mit
uns spricht so dass wir das hier
wirklich gut und informativ überbrücken
können auch sie sind mit sicherheit
gespannt auf die ergebnisse die dort
verkündet werden ich würde gerne da noch
mal den blick etwas weiten weg von von
von den einzelnen impfstoffen aber
vielleicht noch mal hin zur allgemeinen
strategie wo bisch oder wo befinden wir
uns momentan muss man sagen in der nähe
also in dieser momentanen corona lage
wie würden sie die situation einschätzen
wir haben vom rk ii gehört dass die
zahlen wieder steigend man das sehen wir
auch sowieso jeden tag aber das lka
warnt eben auch davor dass die zahlen an
ostern schon wieder höher sein könnten
wie als an weihnachten
wie ist ihre einschätzung der situation
diskutiert ist natürlich auch englich
und verfolgen das engmaschige und wenn
man sich die zahlen anguckt den anstieg
von innerhalb von wenigen tagen dann ist
es natürlich ein sehr steiler anstieg
der relativ daran erinnert wie es halt
vor weihnachten war und wir haben
natürlich jetzt eine situation wo wir
auch noch sehr ansteckende mutationen
oder virusvarianten heißt zirkulieren
haben also insofern ich glaube die
vorsicht und die sorge ist etwas
berechtigt und wir haben natürlich jetzt
auch noch einen großen weg vor uns was
simpson angeht also es sind eigentlich
zwei verläufe die uns ein bisschen
ausbremsen wir müssen auf jeden fall
versuchen die impfkampagne auszuweiten
und da sind ja auch bestrebungen da
jetzt die hausärzte mit ins boot zu
nehmen um das halt schneller
flächendeckender auf den weg zu bringen
und gleichzeitig haben natürlich auch
mehrere länder jetzt die 100 die
hunderte instanz gekippt und haben
notbremsen wieder initiiert und wir in
hamburg sind ja auch davon betroffen
sofern das ist sicherlich eine eine
situation die für eine sehr
ausgemergelte und müde bevölkerung jetzt
noch mal schwer ist aber ich glaube wir
müssen jetzt versuchen noch mal diese
strecke jetzt so zu nehmen wie sie ist
und mit den maßnahmen hoffen diese
situation haben nasa und hätten so dass
die notbremse und vielen
testmöglichkeiten und dem impfen
versuchen das infektionsgeschehen weiter
einzudämmen das ist glaube ich dass das
wird das was ist eminent wichtig es für
uns alle wenn jetzt noch mal auf die
impfstrategie insgesamt schauen das
haben sie auch gerade angesprochen ein
wichtiger aspekt
in der ganzen rechnung ist natürlich
auch die impfung in den hausarztpraxen
die ja dann spätestens ostern oder nach
ostern mitte april beginnen soll was ist
der große vorteil aus ihrer sicht wenn
die hausärztinnen und hausärzte dabei
mitmachen
die hausärztinnen und hausärzte sind ja
wirklich experten was das thema impfen
angeht die haben wir machen das für die
für die grippeimpfung jährlich die
sorgen sich darum dass die bevölkerung
durch geimpft ist aber schon sucht den
impfpass die können einfach noch mal
sie sollen jetzt zusätzlich zu den
impfzentren impfen und ich glaube da
können wir noch mal den reach komplett
weiter ausbauen und vielleicht gibt es
da auch noch andere strategien wo
vielleicht in betrieben geimpft werden
kann also die krankenhäuser machen das
ja sowieso schon da gibt's bei uns am
montag auch wieder los also insofern
glaube ich müssen wir versuchen noch
mehr anstrengungen zu machen mehr leute
zu erreichen das ist glaube ich dass
wichtiger wenn wir jetzt wir haben filme
über astra zeneca gesprochen uns den
markt sozusagen noch mal angucken
momentan fehlt ja im stoff noch
allenthalben es wird zwar auch immer
wieder betont dass einiges jetzt
nachkommen wird in den kommenden monaten
wird mehr impfstoff zur verfügung stehen
dennoch würde es sich aus ihrer sicht
lohnen auch den zum beispiel russischen
impfstoff sputnik wie mit ins angebot zu
nehmen
der impfstoff ist ja auch zur zulassung
bei der emea vorliegend also wenn es
eine europäische zulassung gibt es ist
ja auch eine adenovirus vector impfstoff
runden der gute wirksamkeit gezeigt hat
also wenn eine zulassung wenn das
geprüft wurde von der ma und eine
zulassung in europa vorliegt dann sollte
eigentlich dem nichts entgegenstehen
auch diesen impfstoff mit ins portfolio
zu nehmen das ist ja noch mehrere
impfstoffe die wahrscheinlichste zu
lassen kommen werden in der eu um einen
charakter auch in deutschland
hergestellt wird und auch nowaks ist
sicherlich noch in der pipeline also wir
haben derzeit vier impfstoffe
je mehr impfstoffe wieder im portfolio
haben das so er haben wir die
möglichkeit auch dieses
infektionsgeschehen in den griff zu
bekommen und halt mehr immunität in der
gesellschaft zu erreichen
zu dem thema sputnik wir diesen
impfstoff aus russland hat sich auch der
bundesgesundheitsminister geäußert wir
wollen auch dass gerade uns nochmal
anhören wie er die lage diesbezüglich
einschätzt wir sind im kontakt mit den
russischen kollegen im
gesundheitsministerium auf verschiedenen
ebenen wir unterstützen das unternehmen
dabei auch produktionspartner in
deutschland und europa finden zu können
auch in zusammenarbeit mit dem
wirtschaftsministerium ich will mit all
dem nur deutlich machen wir sind in
engem austausch bis hin zur frage eines
möglichen embryos mit der russischen
seite und ich kann mir auch gut
vorstellen dass wir verträge schließen
auch zügig schließen voraussetzungen ist
aber auch dafür dass wir erst einmal
wissen über welche mengen und welche
verfügbarkeiten wann wir reden weil es
macht ja tatsächlich vor allem dann sinn
wenn dann nach einer zulassung auch
zügig menge verfügbar ist sondern wenn
über diese fragen klarheit es lassen
sich auch verträge schließen und ich bin
tatsächlich sehr dafür wenn die
europäische union jetzt nicht da auch
was macht das wir ist ein national
machen also der herr
bundesgesundheitsminister hat
prinzipiell zumindest wenn dann die
voraussetzungen vorliegen auch nichts
gegen die verwendung von sputnik wie und
sie hatten ihm im prinzip momentan oder
vor kurzem gerade eben schon
beigepflichtet
wir würden gerne noch mal hören suisse
mal youtube welche bürokratischen hürden
sagt sie könnte man abbauen was könnte
man logistisch tun um das impf tempo zu
beschleunigen also den vorhandenen
impfstoff zu verkaufen haben sie da
ideen was man gesagt logistisch besser
machen könnte ich glaube der schritt die
hausärzte und hausarztpraxen mit
einzubeziehen ist schon mal der erste
schritt
wir haben natürlich die internationale
welt anschaut als das gibt es ganz
interessante ansätze gibt es auch drei
bin impfungen also momentan ist ja
unsere limitation vor allem dass wir
nicht genug impfstoff haben aber falls
wir genug impfstoff haben kann man sich
auch noch ganz kreative andere ansätze
überlegen also auch in
kann auch in apotheken werden also das
müssen wir sehen momentan ist das ja
nicht dass limitierende aber ich glaube
es gibt da einige ideen wie man das noch
ausweiten kann aber wenn jetzt schon die
hausarztpraxen mitmachen dann haben wir
glaube ich schon einen ganz großen
schritt getan
große sorge hat in der letzten zeit der
die ausbreitung eben auch von virus
mutationen gemacht auch dazu haben wir
eine frage von christian raith über
facebook gibt es neue kenntnisse darüber
sie fragt jetzt ob der impfstoff von
astrazeneca aber ich denke man kann
ruhig die anderen auch einbeziehen
bei der afrikanischen und der
brasilianischen mutation wirkt man kann
auch nach der britischen mutation fragen
also wie ist das mit der wirksamkeit der
impfstoffe auf die bislang bekannten
mutationen ja also es gibt ja drei
virusvarianten die momentan am meisten
verbreitet sind
die die jetzt setzt man in deutschland
auch den großteil der infektionen stellt
ist ja die britische mutter 21 17 da
gibt es gute wirksamkeit von allen
wirkstoffen immer noch auch wenn es zum
teil etwas eingeschränkt ist aber das
ist noch die guten nachrichten g1 und
die südafrikanische variante sind ja zum
glück in deutschland noch nicht so sehr
verbreitet aber daten aus südafrika
haben als suggeriert dass einige der
impfstoffe unter anderem astrazeneca
oder auch nowaks und auch johnson
johnson hat in südafrika eine geringere
wirksamkeit gezeigt haben wo in
populationen wo diese südafrikanischen
variante dominant war also insofern gibt
es da schon was wir in escape nennen und
das müssen wir sicherlich sehr
engmaschig noch weiter beobachten gut
dazu schon mal vielen dank zu diesen
informationen ich gucke gerade nochmal
auf den monitor aber wir sehen dass wir
immer noch nicht sehen das kann sich
natürlich auch für zögern und genau
würde an dieser stelle gerne noch mal
fragen wie sehen sie denn generell
momentan also ich hatte vorhin schon
gefragt nach der allgemeinen situation
was impfstoffe angeht ist ihnen denn
bange was die nächsten wochen angeht
oder worauf sitzen sie denn jetzt ganz
besonders über das thema test haben wir
auch noch nicht gesprochen
ist das eben auch noch eine wichtige
komponente jetzt im kampf gegen die
pandemie wie bewerten sie das
ich denke schon dass testen eine große
rolle spielen wird auch um halte weitere
öffnung schritte mit zu begleiten also
was kultur angeht schulen
das müssen wir glaube ich irgendwas mit
der test strategien begleiten wir haben
das hier in hamburg ja schon begonnen
dass in den schulen regelmäßig getestet
wird ich glaube damit einen großen
beitrag leisten
und ich glaube diese drei säulen zum
einen maßnahmen die hoffentlich wenn wir
die sind nächste welle wieder eindämmen
können dann auch irgendwann wieder
gelockert werden können begleitet durch
test strategien und halt einen rühren
immunschutz in der bevölkerung durch
impfungen
das wird die strategie sein die und dann
langfristig aus der pandemie herausführt
darauf hoffen wir sehr frau professor
alle war dass marilyn ag aus hamburg
vielen dank für diese informationen und
dass sie sich jetzt die zeit für uns
genommen haben
wir warten immer noch auf die
bundeskanzlerin trotzdem danke und alles
gute nach hamburg dankeschön für diese
informationen so und wie gesagt wir
warten wir schalten aber in der zeit
noch mal quer durch die republik hätte
ich jetzt fast gesagt wir schalten noch
mal nach berlin in unser
hauptstadtstudio denn da wartet meine
kollegin schack und alaa banerjee da
steht sie oder beziehungsweise sitzt sie
hätte wenn ich sie hallo hug und alle
einen schönen guten abend ja wie sieht's
aus wie ist die lage vor ort also wir
haben die kanzlerin noch nicht gesehen
gibt es irgendetwas was bislang nach
außen gedrungen ist was kann man sagen
nein das ist eine der runden aus der
nicht so viel nach draußen dringt wir
hatten ja in den letzten monaten gesehen
dass zunehmend wenn die kanzlerin und
die ministerpräsidentinnen
zusammensitzen
doch der ein oder andere was raus
schickt bis heute ist es ein bisschen
ruhiger
vielleicht weil man sich wirklich sehr
darauf konzentriert jetzt die punkte
durchzugehen die für die impfstrategie
auch wichtig sind nachdem man ja gestern
vorgestern kurz unsicher war ob das
ganze aus der kurve fliegt als
astrazeneca mal
kurz auf der kippe stand wir warten also
momentan noch genauso gespannt wie ihr
was wird denn jetzt von dieser runde
heute erwartet also das ist eben das
bund länder treffen das jetzt schon ein
paar mal gegeben aber die impf gipfel
hat natürlich noch mal eine besondere
strahlkraft würde ich jetzt fast sagen
und auch eine erwartung natürlich
geweckt gerade nach dem was jetzt diese
woche war auch mit dem impfstoff von
astrazeneca
was erhofft man sich jetzt von diesem
gipfel
die hoffnungen sind natürlich maximal
würde ich mal sagen weil eben mit der
impfstrategie und dem testen ja auch die
öffnungs strategie steht und fällt am
montag wollen sich will sich dieselbe
runde zusammensetzen und dann gucken was
machen wir jetzt angesichts steigender
infektionszahlen und trotzdem diesem
großen großen wunsch wieder mehr
normalität zuzulassen und auch zu
differenzierteren modellen zu kommen
das geht eben nur wenn man zügig impft
jetzt ist ja seit gestern abend klar
dass astrazeneca weiter eingesetzt
werden kann und was wir jetzt schon
vorliegen haben ist ein beschlussentwurf
das sind drei seiten auf denen sich auf
den ski ziert ist welche schritte man
gehen möchte und darüber beugen sich
jetzt eben gerade die bundeskanzlerin
und die ministerpräsidenten unter
gesundheitsminister
da geht es vor allem darum zu gucken wie
schafft man es jetzt noch in den
nächsten wochen möglichst schnell das
tempo zu steigern beim impfen obwohl der
impfstoff weiter knapp sein wird also
das steht gleich vorne mit drin
das natürlich nach wie vor nicht genug
impfstoff da sein wird
man möchte zügig die hausärzte
hausarztpraxen einbinden und
gleichzeitig fragt man sich wie kriegt
man die priorisierung trotzdem noch hin
will
der grundgedanke war ja wenn zu wenig
impfstoff da ist sollten auf jeden fall
erst diejenigen geimpft werden die
besonders vulnerable sind also besonders
gefährdet falls sie sich infizieren mit
dem saas kopf 2 virus und das ist jetzt
das was die runde hier austariert jetzt
war der bundesgesundheits
minister aber auch der experte der spd
professor karl lauterbach ja auch schon
zu hören heute unter anderem eben auch
mit der einschätzung dass es wieder zu
einem lockdown kommen muss auch da
vielleicht gerade noch mal die frage ist
das nicht dann auch schwer sozusagen der
bevölkerung zu vermitteln die ja schon
so lange darauf wartet dass es endlich
mal wieder eben lockerungen gibt jetzt
kamen die gerade und jetzt muss man
wahrscheinlich zurück in den lock down
so es zumindest jetzt meine einschätzung
gewesen nach den heutigen äußerungen
was erwartet man da ist auch ein
kommunikationsproblem oder ja ich bin
mir nicht sicher ob das jetzt nur noch
ein kommunikationsproblem ist war
mittlerweile sieht man dass das was
jetzt monatelang und eigentlich im
ganzen letzten jahr immer als gemeinsame
linie aufgebaut und verkauft worden ist
von bund und ländern so brüchig geworden
ist das ist dass es schon zerfasert und
so franz also wir haben sehr viele
unterschiedliche ansätze
es gibt bundesländer die sagen wir
müssen ganz hart die notbremse ziehen
also die öffnungen die wir jetzt gerade
eingeführt haben sofort wieder
zurücknehmen sachsen gehört dazu
die hat waren schon beim letzten mal mit
dem beschluss nicht einverstanden haben
gesagt dass es leichtsinnig da fühlt man
sich jetzt bestätigt durch die zeigen
steigenden infektionszahlen dann gibt es
wiederum andere die sagen na ja also
ganz so kategorisch kann man es nicht
sehen und man sollte wenigstens schauen
was man zum beispiel beim beim urlaub im
eigenen bundesland möglich macht aus
mecklenburg vorpommern haben wir dann
manuela schwesig heute gehört die gesagt
hat naja wenn man urlaub in mallorca
erlaubt dann ist das wahrscheinlich
riskanter als urlaub in einer
ferienwohnung für bewohner eines
bundeslandes im eigenen bundesland also
da ist jeder ganz viel diskussion drin
der druck ist sehr groß und auch
deswegen eben heute diese frage wie
bekommt man da den druck raus indem man
schneller impft was ich interessant
finde an dem beschluss den wir hier
haben ist das wirklich ganz konkret mit
zahlen gearbeitet wird und dass auch
kleine erfolge hier schon sehr groß
gefeiert werden
da steht zum beispiel drin man bekommt
aus einem eu kontingent zusätzlichen
impfstoff von biontech insgesamt 580.000
impfdosen was natürlich in der in der
breite nicht besonders viel ist aber die
freude ist offensichtlich wirklich
der groß weil ja auch durchgerechnet
wird wie viel davon an die hausärzte
gehen soll wie viel davon an die an die
impfzentren gehen soll und dass davon
auch ein teil
ein besonders gefährdete grenzregionen
gehen soll in nachbarschaft zu
frankreich in nachbarschaft zu
tschechien das wären dann das saarland
bayern thüringen und sachsen die hier
ganz konkret aufgezählt werden das ist
in dem beschluss stehen dann noch exe
für die zahl für die frage wie viele
impfdosen bekommen diese bundesländer
für ihre hotspots also da sieht man es
richtet sich wirklich die hoffnung auf
jede einzelne impfdosis und die frage
wie verteilt man das jetzt am besten und
am schnellsten ist denn eigentlich der
tatsache dass die bundeskanzlerin selbst
nachher ans mikrofon treten wird und
nicht etwa der bundesgesundheitsminister
ist die irgendwie besonders
interpretierbar ist das einfach nur noch
mal ein zeichen um zu unterstreichen wie
wichtig jetzt die entscheidungen des
tages sind oder kann man da auch
irgendwie daraus ersehen dass
vertrauensverhältnisse vielleicht
irgendwie getrübt sind beispielsweise
zwischen der kanzlerin und ihrem
gesundheitsminister also letzteres würde
ich da raus jetzt nicht lesen denn die
bundeskanzlerin geht ja immer nach den
bund länder runden tatsächlich vor die
vor die kameras das werden wir nächsten
montag auch wieder sehen aber in der tat
würde ich auch sagen dass sie sich auch
heute obwohl es eine kleinere runde ist
die sich nur mit einem thema befasst
selber dorthin stellen wird ist schon
ein zeichen dafür dass sie auch wieder
als gesicht und als stimme hörbar sein
möchte und da auch eine deutliche
botschaft raus schicken möchte es ist
natürlich für sie auch nicht ganz
unangenehm wenn sie sich in dem moment
hinstellen kann wo man auch was
konkretes vorzuweisen hat denn sie hatte
in den letzten monaten relativ häufig
auch im pressekonferenz nach dem bund
länder runden sitzen müssen wo sie sagen
musste dass es eigentlich nicht mein
beschluss sie hat es nicht wörtlich so
gesagt aber sie hat schon öfter
durchscheinen lassen dass sie nicht
einverstanden war mit den mit der frage
wie weit die schritte gingen die dann
die bundesländer mehrheitlich wollten
heute könnte ein tag sein an dem sie
einmal da stehen kann und sagen kann das
ist ein guter beschluss da stehe ich
voll und ganz dahinter und sie kann eben
wieder eine strategie
präsentieren auf die deutschland
tatsächlich ja auch wartet ja das wäre
vielleicht insofern auch nicht ganz
unwichtig vielleicht nicht für frau
merkel persönlich aber vielleicht auch
für die union denn die ist nun zuletzt
ziemlich unter druck geraten und wir
haben ein super wahljahr also wie
wichtig ist vielleicht auch so als
allgemeine politische einschätzung jetzt
für die union vielleicht auch gerade
dass diese impfkampagne fahrt gewinnt
das ist enorm wichtig also für die union
ist jeder punkt an dem sie jetzt wieder
sicherheit gewinnen kann und an dem sie
zeigen kann dass sie in der lage ist die
krise zu managen 1 1 punkte der sie vor
dem weiteren absturz bewahrt denn sie
hat jetzt tatsächlich in letzter zeit
sehr viel kritik auf sich gezogen die
die bundesminister die am meisten in der
kritik standen in dieser pandemie
namentlich der gesundheitsminister und
der wirtschaftsminister gehören zur
union
zuletzt kamen dann noch die affäre um
die masken beschaffung und die
bereicherung bei abgeordneten von cdu
und csu dazu und wir haben es bei den
landtagswahlen schon gesehen in
schlechteren ergebnissen in historisch
schlechten ergebnissen muss man ja sagen
und das obwohl viele wählerinnen und
wähler in der briefwahl ihre stimme
abgegeben haben bevor die der masken
skandal bekanntgeworden ist dass es
hätte sogar noch schlimmer kommen können
und es ist ganz klar dass die union
jetzt versuchen muss wieder vertrauen
zurückzugewinnen sie weiß ganz sicher
wie schwierig das ist wir leben das hier
jeden tag dass die nervosität innerhalb
der union groß ist auch die
anstrengungen mit dem masten skandal
aufzuräumen sind groß werden aber auch
kritisiert weil es stimmen gibt die
sagen das geht alles nicht weit genug
das ist alles nicht konsequent genug
wenn ich das noch hinzufügen darf jetzt
zuletzt ein weiterer rücktritt in der
csu nicht wegen einer maske affäre aber
da ist eben wieder jemand zurückgetreten
der gesagt hat ich habe mir noch mal
genau angeguckt was ich in den letzten
jahren gemacht habe
und das ist wohl mit dem politischen
kompass und der politischen moral nicht
zu vereinbaren das ist aber nicht
aufgefallen weil die fraktionen ihre
ehrenerklärung gefordert hat wir hatten
eben von allen abgeordneten gefordert
und da schreibt man bitte dass ihr euch
an masten nicht bereichert haben sondern
das ist ein fall der außerhalb die
der ehrenerklärung lag da gibt es eben
kritik dass die fraktionen dann nicht
mehr ganz grundsätzlich gesagt hat
überprüft bitte eure tätigkeit sondern
nur nach den masken geschäften gefragt
hat soweit die einschätzungen von schack
und manager aus unserem hauptstadtstudio
vielleicht gerade noch mal die frage
kannst du denn auch ungefähr schon
einschätzen wann es wohl zu dieser
pressekonferenz kommen wird wir warten
ja nun schon ein weilchen
ich weiß gar nicht ob die beteiligten
das selber sagen können ich habe mal vor
einer halben stunde vorsichtig
nachgefragt und da gab es noch keine
antwort darauf
es gibt ja auch in diesem beschluss
tatsächlich noch ein paar punkte die die
strittig sind also es geht zum beispiel
um die um die frage müssen die hausärzte
wenn sie dann eingebunden sind auch die
priorisierung beachten da wissen wir
dass bayern sich wünschen würde dass
etwas flexibler zu handhaben die wollen
nicht das drin steht ihr müsst sondern
die hätten gerne dass drinsteht wir
empfehlen das für die hausärzte
das sind zwei punkte über die man
sicherlich sich nochmal trefflich die
köpfe zerbrechen kann und und heiß reden
kann und das kann schon sein dass ist
bei diesen runden öfters mal so dass ein
punkt dann doch länger dauert als sich
alle das vorgestellt haben wir hatten
damit gerechnet dass die pressekonferenz
am nachmittag beginnt sind auch
journalistinnen und journalisten schon
reingelassen worden so ab 16 uhr 30 aber
das heißt dieser tage eben nichts also
wir hatten schon runden wohl die
kolleginnen dort sehr sehr viele stunden
gesessen haben bis es dann losging
so schlimm wird es hoffentlich heute
nicht das erwartet zumindest keine aber
wir können es momentan nicht genau sagen
wann es los
da schließen wir uns doch diese hoffnung
an sowohl für euch in berlin als auch
für uns denn wir warten ja auch noch ein
bisschen wir haben heute schon die
kollegen gesehen danke 12 stark und wir
haben gerade schon die kollegen auch
gesehen die sich da ist gemütlich
gemacht haben
im kanzleramt und immer noch eben warten
auf die kanzlerin und ihr statement so
wir sind aber vorbereitet und haben eine
weitere gesprächspartnerin nämlich
ulrike krug frau doktor ulrike groos sie
ist landärztin in altenstadt im
hessischen wetteraukreis unter anderem
auch mutter von zwei kindern schönen
guten abend frau grob bloggerin und
buchautorin und eben wie gesagt
auch ärztin und deswegen vielleicht auch
gerade noch einmal an sie die frage frau
trug sie haben sich kritisch geäußert
jetzt in den letzten tagen da waren sie
mit sicherheit nicht die einzige
vielleicht können sie gerade nochmal
zusammenfassung worin ihre kritik an der
derzeitigen situation besteht also ein
ganz großer kritikpunkt meinerseits war
dass ich fand dass wir hausärzte viel zu
spät eingebunden wurden oder eben noch
gar nicht eingebunden sind
es ist so dass wir ja als hausärzte
eigentlich die profis für das impfen
sind und der astra zenica impfstoff auch
wenn er jetzt einige tage auf eis lag
wortwörtlich von uns verimpft hätte
werden können und da habe ich nicht ganz
nachvollziehen können dass die
entscheidung immer wieder vertagt wurde
und ist am ende hieß na ja erst im april
und dann ende april und eventuell sogar
erst im mai da finde ich dass wir
unseren beitrag leisten könnten
den könnten sie schon vorher leisten
frau dr
die frage ist vielleicht auch ganz
allgemein mal warum geht das eigentlich
mit dem impfen in den hausarztpraxen
besser und schneller als in den
impfzentren die wurden ja dafür eigens
eigentlich ins leben gerufen
jetzt hat man aber den eindruck es wäre
alles viel besser wenn das über die
hausärzte ärztinnen und ärzte laufen
würde vielleicht können sie das gerade
noch mal erklären
da muss man schon differenzieren also
die impfzentren haben natürlich ihren
sinn und zweck um große massen an
patienten impfen zu können und eben auch
denen die em-arena impfstoffe zu
verkämpfen das ist etwas was wir
wahrscheinlich eine hausarztpraxis
wirklich nicht so gut leisten könnten
weil die ja bei minus 70 grad gelagert
werden müssen
das ist mit dem astra weniger impfstoff
anders nichtsdestotrotz ist es so dass
wir als in den praxen unsere patienten
sehr gut kennen
wir wissen wer mobil ist wir sind auch
natürlich mobil und können zu unseren
patienten fahren die eben nicht in die
weiter entfernten impfzentren gehen
können und damit ist das schon mal so
dass diese patientengruppe ja den
impfstoff erhält es gibt immer noch 80
jährige die keinen
eine impfung haben und ich denke die
impfung parallel in impfzentren und bei
uns hausärzte
das würde sicherlich den entscheidenden
faktor dazu beitragen dass es schneller
geht
ist es denn für sie eigentlich
organisatorisch schwierig die impf
reihenfolge also die priorisierung dies
ergibt einzuhalten oder ist das für sie
kein problem so rein organisatorisch
nein das ist kein problem also wir
kennen ja unsere patienten
wir wissen wer bevorzugt geimpft werden
muss
wir wissen wen wir ein bestellen können
oder zu wem wir fahren müssen das ist ja
der vorteil an der praxis wir wir müssen
ja auch die atteste schreiben für die
bevorzugte info in der zeit in der wir
die impfung geschrieben hätten hätte ich
schon längst durchgeführt
tja das ist allerdings auch war generell
die frage vielleicht noch mal was das
essen angeht es gibt ja sowieso einem
teil der bevölkerung der skeptisch ist
was impfungen generell bedeuten aber
eben auch was jetzt gerade natürlich im
letzten fall jetzt mit astrazeneca wie
nehmen sie das wahr also ist da jetzt
die impfskepsis gestiegen und glauben
sie dass sie das vertrauen gerade jetzt
in den letztgenannten impfstoff wieder
zurückgewinnen können ich merke schon
dass eine gewisse skepsis da ist aber
die bestand schon vorher da hat einfach
eine kommunikation stattgefunden die für
das vertrauen nicht zuträglich war
auch bei den bayern tick impfstoff ich
habe anfangs oder für die ärmeren stoffe
generell ich habe anfangs sehr gegen
windmühlen gekämpft weil ich aufgeklärt
habe dass die m rna impfstoff sicher und
effektiv sind und das ist jetzt sehr
wieder aus dem fokus geraten seitdem die
astra zenica impfstoffe in verruf
geraten sind und jetzt müssen wir den im
prinzip wieder
ja den müssen wir da müssen wir das
vertrauen den patienten zurück gewinnen
können und das schaffen wir schon wieder
fragen wie wie machen sie das also wie
sprechen sie auch vielleicht generell
mit impfgegnern oder leuten die sehr
skeptisch sind wie versuchen sie die zu
überzeugen
generell ist wichtig die sorgen ernst zu
nehmen also wenn ich jetzt sofort auf
konfrontation gehe und die sorgen nicht
ernst nehmen und sagen das ist alles
quatsch dann baue ich mauern auf ist ist
ja so dass die meist die skepsis nicht
aus irgendeinem fanatismus geschieht
sondern aus ängsten sorgen irgendwelchen
sachen die man irgendwo gelesen oder
gehört hat und da kann man mit viel zeit
kann man schon aufklären es gibt auch
dinge die einfach nicht gewusst werden
und letztlich vielleicht auch mit
vorbild vorangehen
ja ich glaube dass es da einfach viele
verschiedene möglichkeiten gibt wichtig
ist eben das unternehmen wird über
youtube fragt uns frau dr co bekommen
denn die hausärzte geld pro impfung also
das ist ja ein generelles thema es wird
ja oft gesagt dass wir hausärzte unseren
impfung dumm und dämlich verdienen aber
es wird ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht
weil wir noch nicht so weit sind
was für ein was wir für eine krone
impfung bekommen aber es ist nicht so
also eigentlich wissen wir es gerade
noch gar nicht also wir planen das nicht
um dadurch reich zu werden wenn man sie
jetzt das beispiel influenza-impfung mal
zu grunde legt da gibt es ungefähr acht
euro pro impfung und ich denke daran
sieht man schon dass das nichts ist was
wir machen um geld zu verdienen ja also
das nehmen wir ihnen ab dass das nicht
ihre erste primäre motivation ist die
gretchenfrage kriegen wir auch noch
geradezu geschickt ob die impfte das
virus noch weitergeben können genau das
ist eine frage die auch schon seit
vielen wochen monaten eigentlich
diskutiert wird denn davon hängt ja auch
viel ab haben sie da erkenntnisse zu es
gibt ja untersuchungen dazu dass das
virus dann wohl nicht weitergegeben kann
gleich
obwohl man da glaube ich auch noch in
den studien einfach noch ein bisschen
weiter schauen muss ich denke da wir es
ja wichtig infektiologen genauer zu
fragen
momentan ist es so dass wir auf den
stand der dinge sind dass das virus dann
nicht weitergegeben kann es gibt aber
auch fälle in denen das virus sich wohl
trotzdem verbreitet hat ich glaube das
ist noch zu früh um da einen definitiven
aussage zu treffen
können sie verstehen dass es dann
trotzdem also frustrierend ist das
beispielsweise altersheim oder cafés
immer noch nicht aufmachen auch wenn es
heißt die leute sind geimpft also das
ist ja auch irgendwie widersprüchlich
man hat so das gefühl okay also
einerseits gelte ich dann als geimpft
oder bin geben wird auf der anderen
seite trautmann aber offenbar dann doch
dem impfstoff nicht so ganz über den weg
also welche schlüsse soll ich denn
daraus ziehen wenn ich dann geimpfter
bin
die vorsicht die müssen wir alle noch
walten lassen ich weiß auch nicht ob das
jetzt gerade zuträglich wäre wenn alle
die geimpft werden dann ganz viele
freiheiten genießen könnten weil man
sich aktuell auch nicht anhand der
priorisierung aussuchen kann ob man
jetzt schon vorgezogen wird oder nicht
deswegen ist das ja auch eine sache der
solidarität ich kenne die argumente
bezüglich freiheitsberaubung dass die
menschen ihre freiheit zurück gelangen
müssen wenn sie geimpft sind
das stimmt natürlich muss man darüber
diskutieren aber solange wir eben noch
nicht wirklich wissen wie ansteckend man
noch ist und wir diese steigenden zahlen
und die mutation haben ist das ja alles
spekulation und dann so lange kann man
eben leider noch nicht geschäfte
restaurants öffnen
ja wo wir gerade bei frustrierenden
themen sind es ist ja jetzt auch eben
wieder die rede davon dass eben die
zahlen aufgrund eben der mutationen doch
zu steigen dass man jetzt eben
vermutlich dann in den nächsten tagen
doch wieder zu einem erneuten shutdown
kommen wird wie ist das aus ihrer sicht
halten sie das für sinnvoll
ich mache mich mit dem typen mal
unbeliebt aber ich bin definitiv immer
für einen harten lockdown wenn es darum
geht die zahlen einzuschränken ich habe
das im november schon mal gesagt dass
diese halbherzigen maßnahmen nicht zu
den ergebnissen führen die wir bräuchten
und ich denke wenn wir jetzt noch die
zähne zusammenbeißen und dann mit dem
impfen schneller vorankommen mit den
test strategien dann wird es jetzt noch
einmal blöd und dann kann man aber auch
wieder aufatmen aber wenn wir immer so
seicht vor uns hin dümpeln dann werden
wir leider aus der dritten welle nicht
mehr herauskommen ohne dass es
unangenehm wird also sie würden sich
dafür aussprechen hierbei möglichst bald
und dann auch möglichst rigoros diesen
shutter und vorzunehmen
ja ich halte das für sinnvoll
wie ist es denn eigentlich aus ihrer
sicht was die übertragung angeht ich
meine das ist ja auch themen die uns
jetzt eigentlich schon während der
ganzen pandemie beschäftigen wo finden
die übertragung über hauptstadt ist man
da aus ihrer sicht weiter gekommen
können sie sagen na ja das sollte man
darauf sollte man besonders achten
das sind besondere treiber auch der
pandemie wie gestaltet sich das so an
der praxis was was machen sie da für
beobachtungen die beobachtungen sind
dass das natürlich im näheren umfeld
passiert also momentan jetzt mit der
neuen mutation mit der britischen
mutation die einzelnen 7 bekommen wir
immer mehr mit dass die ansteckung in
kindergärten passieren zum beispiel und
sich dann die eltern anstecken oder die
erzieherinnen und das ob das jetzt ein
treiber ist dass ich habe keine zahlen
dazu ich kann in meiner subjektiven
eindruck aus der praxis nennen aber das
ist momentan so mein eindruck oft sind
das kurze kontakte die geschehen weil
man in dem moment nicht darüber
nachdenkt dass es eben eine ansteckende
eine hochansteckende krankheit sein kann
der kurze kontakt im treppenhaus
mal schnell dem nachbarn irgendwie
helfen und man trägt dann in dem moment
keine maske ja das sind so denke ich die
die die haupt ansteckung punkte
gemeinsam im auto fahren
fahrgemeinschaften solche sache wenn wir
jetzt noch mal ein bisschen den den
allgemeinen blick auch auf das ganze
bemühen wollen also wenn sie jetzt so
die letzten wochen und monate beobachten
ich habe es eingangs gesagt sie haben es
ja auch schon angesprochen was ihre
kritik angeht was würden sie sich denn
jetzt für die nächste zeit wünschen
einen punkt haben sie genannt das ist
dass das die hausärztinnen und hausärzte
auch stärker zum einsatz kommen aber wie
fühlen sie sich denn generell momentan
auch gerade als medizinerin
durch diese zeit begleitet auch von
unserer regierung
ich habe das gefühl dass die
wissenschaftliche meinungen nicht so
ernst genommen wird wie sie vielleicht
ernst genommen werden sollte also es ist
ja nicht so dass erst seit gestern
gewarnt wird dass die mutation sich weit
verbreiten wird dass wir in die dritte
welle schlittern dass wir unbedingt
tempo beim impfen machen müssen und
vorher bitte nicht lockern sollten
das sind punkte die ich kritisiere und
ich denke es sollte auf jeden fall jetzt
nicht weiter geöffnet werden ich stelle
in der praxis fest dass auch die folgen
der das lockt downs steigen also sei es
depressive verstimmungen bewegungsmangel
macht sich bemerkbar dass das sind alles
folgen nichtsdestotrotz glaube ich nicht
dass wir was davon haben wenn wir jetzt
noch wochenlang so weiter machen das
hatte ich ja schon gesagt wie gesagt es
wird ja nicht erst seit gestern gewarnt
dass wir in die dritte welle kommen aber
es wurde ignoriert finde ich es doch
richtig aussprechen über youtube fragt
uns frau stock glauben sie nicht auch
dass die politiker deswegen mit den
hausärzten bremsen weil sie angst haben
dass die hausärzte nicht gleich neutral
priorisieren also die frage offenbar
danach ob da nicht mehr bekannte der
onkel der schwager wasser ist
dann schneller zum zuge kommt als einer
der es eigentlich dringender bräuchte ja
das ist ja so einer der kritikpunkte die
ich auch öfter gelesen habe dass man
vermutet dass wir hausärzte dann zur
wild durcheinander impfen
das kann ich natürlich so nicht
bestätigen weil es ist ja so dass wir
unseren versorgungsauftrag haben und wir
als hausärzte schon ganz genau wissen
wer diese impfung jetzt dringend
benötigt und es gibt keinen grund
jemanden vorzuziehen der definitiv
gesünder ist als die 80 jährige
patientin der 90 jährige patient mit den
vorerkrankungen
ich finde diese kritik definitiv nicht
angebracht zumal wir auch schon
mitbekommen haben dass es auch in den
impfzentren viele leute gab die sich da
offensichtlich irgendwo ihre impfungen
geholt haben ja alle teilen diese kritik
auch nicht ich habe es nur vorgelesen
wir wir lassen eben auch unsere user
hier zu wort kommen
andrea es ebenfalls über youtube erfragt
eigentlich nicht sondern stellt fest
hausärzte erreichen oft besser die
älteren menschen meine über 80 jährige
tante will auch nicht in ein impfzentrum
und wartet auf den hausarzt das
vielleicht auch noch ein interessanter
aspekt ich meinen sohn ins zentrum das
wirkt ja irgendwo auch ein bisschen
anonym man kennt ja die leute vor ort
auch nicht
ich könnte mir vorstellen dass die
bereitschaft sich impfen zu lassen auch
auf der anderen seite also bei den zu
impfenden steigt wenn man eben
denjenigen camps leben von vornimmt
ja das kann ich definitiv bestätigen
ich habe das jeden tag mehrfach dass
patienten patientinnen zu mir sagen wann
im tier waren impfen sie dann endlich
ich warte mal lieber bis ihr das macht
also mir wäre es lieber ich könnte hier
zu euch kommen ihr kennt mich doch das
kann ich so bestätigen also auch das
vertrauen wird uns ganz offen
ausgesprochen ich lass das lieber hier
machen und gehe nicht in irgendeinen ins
zentrum
ja das kann ich auch verstehen er detlef
gieseke über facebook schließlich fragt
noch frau doktor ist sie schon geimpft
worden
einfache frage
ja ich bin definitiv schon gehen ich bin
anfang januar schon geimpft worden
dadurch dass ich in den impfzentren
mitarbeiter ja nur das leuchtet ein und
dann aber vielleicht noch die frage
haben sie wert darauf gelegt dass es ein
bestimmter impfstoff ist oder würden sie
jeden empfehlen können und auch nehmen
selbst nehmen ja als ich gebe foto gab
es nur bei und ich auch so also ich
hatte da sozusagen gar nicht die wahl
aber ich kann auf jeden fall sagen dass
unser gesamtes praxispersonal mit
astrazeneca geimpft ist und das alles
wunderbar geklappt hat natürlich gab es
in fraktionen das kann man nicht
verleugnen fieber schüttelfrost sowas
tritt auf wir hatten jetzt zum glück
nicht die schweren impfreaktionen
feststellen können
gerade da vielleicht als
servicecharakter eben auch noch mal kurz
darauf hinweisen wenn jemand sich impfen
lässt jetzt egal mit welchem impfstoff
ab wann sollte er sozusagen noch mal
rücksprache halten mit seiner hausärztin
seinem hausarzt oben bis wann ist es
sozusagen eine normale reaktion auf eine
impfung die als nicht jetzt irgendwie
besonders beängstigend oder
besorgniserregend wahrgenommen werden
sollte also schlicht und einfach gesagt
bei sorgen immer also bei sorgen kann
man sein hausarzt ein haus sind immer
ansprechen
auch wenn das nach 24 stunden sein
sollte alles was in einem normalen
rahmen liegt denn wir erwarten nach
einer impfung also bis 48 stunden fieber
schüttelfrost ist vollkommen normal
auch kopfschmerzen sind dann noch normal
wenn aber unsicherheiten auftreten dafür
sind wir ja da dann soll man uns
ansprechen und fragen und wenn das jetzt
deutlich länger als diese 48 stunden ist
dann kann man schon sagen dann natürlich
also auf uns zukommen und wir klären das
gut dann nehmen wir das gerne noch mal
mit als schlusswort frau dr rieke cook
war das aus altenstadt in hessen
bloggerin und buchautorin und vor allem
auch ärztin dankeschön dass sie uns ihre
sicht der dinge auch noch mal nach nahe
gebracht haben dankeschön und einen
schönen abend und wir gucken gerade noch
mal bei der gelegenheit auf die
bundespressekonferenz bzw
das ist es nicht das kanzleramt aber
sehen dass da eben auch noch kein
weiteres geschehen zu erkennen ist
aber wir sind immer noch vorbereitet und
sprechen nun mit dem spd
gesundheitsexperten karl lauterbach da
sehe ich ihn schon sitzen hinter mir
einen schönen guten abend herr
lauterbach prima dass sie sich auch die
zeit für uns nehmen ja wir warten immer
noch auf die bundeskanzlerin haben sich
schon was gehört gehört schon allerdings
also die ergebnisse werden von der post
selbst vorgetragen da will man nicht
vorher greifen dann das gehört hier
nicht hin aber nicht dass du kannst es
sehr wichtig dass wir heute diesen
gipfel haben und sicherlich eine
wichtige schaltstelle jetzt klar zu
machen wie wir in den nächsten wochen
vorgehen werden was erhoffen sie sich
denn mal so ungefragt von diesem
impfgipfel heute in welche richtung
sollte es denn ihrer meinung nach gehen
also dass man sich dass es sehr wichtig
dass wir die im freien folge nicht
verändern die im verein vor wie sage ich
genau richtig für das was wir jetzt in
den nächsten wochen erwarten müssen
nämlich schwere dritte welle die gefehlt
insbesondere diejenigen die in den
risikogruppen 12 und alles sollte neben
stoffe auch schwerpunktmäßig eingesetzt
werden darüber hinaus die rechnung der
also hausarztpraxen für die impfung ist
ebenfalls richtig
und dann ist man schon wann der eben
stoff dafür ausreicht man jetzt
unbedingt mindestens eine million
impfdosen benötigen um das
sinnvollerweise hinten zu können also
pro woche und das ist etwas sollte man
vielleicht erreichen könnte in der
zweiten aprilhälfte wir haben ja gerade
mit einer hausärztin gesprochen die
selber sehr gerne impfen würde ähnliche
töne sind von anderen haus setzen ja
auch schon länger zu vernehmen warum
dauert es so lange bis die loslegen
können
das ist einfach nicht genug geben jedoch
da zum jetzigen zeitpunkt würde es gar
keinen sinn machen weil das wir haben
derzeit noch zu wenig impfstoff um die
impfzeiten auszulasten die wir aufgebaut
haben die auch gut funktionieren und
somit würde man jetzt die praxen
also öffnet dann wirklich situationen
vorher hätte ich dann zu wenig impfstoff
für die impfzentren da halte ich zu
wenig impfstoff pdf zentrum und sie aus
erste ja das bringt uns natürlich wieder
zu der frage warum ist so wenig
impfstoff da ich weiß dass sie nicht
gerne zurück schauen sondern lieber nach
vorne und ich aber trotzdem noch mal die
frage ich meine das stellt sich nun halt
im moment jeden tag oder auch fast alle
unsere zuschauer mit sicherheit fragen
sich eben warum ist nicht mehr stoff
vorhanden wann kommt mehr
wie sind ihre einschätzungen dazu zum
einen warum ist nicht mehr da und wann
kommt mehr
also warum nicht mehr da ist kann man
ganz einfach also zuordnen europäischen
union ist es einfach nicht gelungen
dafür zu sorgen dass mehr kapazität zur
produktion aufgebaut wurde somit mandat
im wesentlichen bestellt aber man hat
das bestellt was produziert werden
konnte in den bestehenden
produktionskapazitäten bestehen dann
seien weil fabrikationen zahlen man hat
keinen neuen stand aufgebaut das haben
die amerikaner besser gemacht ja anhalt
investiert in den aufbau neuer
kapazitäten und das ist sicherlich etwas
was die eu nicht in dieser form noch mal
machen würde
also sie haben die große hoffnung das
ist dann zumindest wenn der ähnliche
fall noch einmal eintritt dann besser
laufen würde ist jetzt natürlich ein
schwacher trost aber wie rechnen sie
jetzt bzw
kalkulieren sie in den nächsten wochen
mit welcher menge ungefähr ein impfstoff
der dann vorhanden sein wird
es kommt sehr darauf an also auch die
erste celica impfstofflieferungen also
die uns zugesagt worden sind auch
vorkommen also also vollständig ankommen
weil das unser zweitwichtigster
impfstoff wir haben wir leider sehr
wenig moderner im stoff besorgen können
und somit ist die situation wie folgt zu
bescheiden also wenn wir glück haben
dann können wir halt in den nächsten
monaten etwa 30 millionen bürger inseln
zu denen also geimpften die wir schon
haben ist dann ungefähr die hälfte der
bürger in den nächsten monaten in farbe
die wirklich kritische phase sind die
nächsten wochen wo wir eben noch wenig
zusätzlichen finden wo die impfmenge
noch nicht deutlich steigen wer aber in
einander folgen bedeuten
die reinkommen damit sind die nächsten
wochen die beschnittene besonders
schwierigen weil es im tempo kann nicht
erhöht werden es nicht so gebe es doch
da die dritte welle mit der besonders
ansteckend dazu hat uns aber schon
erreicht sie leiten daraus die forderung
ab dass es noch mal zu einem harten
lockdown kommen sollte ab nächster woche
wenn sich hier richtig wenn ich sie
richtig verstanden habe das ist alles
andere als populär das wissen sie selbst
aber vielleicht können sie nochmal
erklären warum das jetzt genau wichtig
ist dass jetzt möglichst schnell wieder
eben zu machen
also wir haben jetzt ein exponentielles
wachstum schon erreicht und das geht von
alleine nicht weg wenn man einmal
exponentiellen wachstum ist dann kommen
wir aus dem experimentellen wachstum nur
heraus indem man die kontakte wieder
runter fährt das die einzige möglichkeit
das exponentielle wachstum dass ich auch
noch beschleunigen
nämlich dann wenn der anteil der
mutation fast 100 prozent beträgt das
wird anfang april das ist ein anfang
mitte april wird er jetzt also sagen wir
dann so weitermachen wie jetzt dann
hätten wir mitte oder ende april
spätestens mit einem neuen zuletzt rund
200 pro sieben tage pro 100000 so
erwartet zu rechnen
das würde dann ein paar wochen später
dazu führen dass intensiv dazu massiv
überlastet sind
und wiederum ein paar wochen später dass
wir deutlich steigende sterbezahlen das
können wir uns einfach nicht leisten
ich fände es eben sehr sehr traurig wenn
wir vermeidbare weise so wenige wochen
vor der impfung von diesem hoch risiko
wochen tatsächlich die infektionszahlen
steigen ließ und so dass es dann noch
mal vater
belek von menschen die chronisch krank
werden oder grafisch etwas normalfall
gewesen wäre
daher würde ich jetzt noch mal in einem
hocker und investieren um das rettende
ufer der impfung erhalten
das wollen wir an dieser stelle
vielleicht auch nicht verschweigen es
gibt viele sympathien die ihnen
entgegengebracht werden auch hier bei
uns und unseren sozialen netzwerken
andreas über youtube professor
lauterbach zum beispiel schreibt danke
für ihre arbeit und bleiben sie auch
gesund also auch solche stimmen gibt es
das wird also durchaus auch positiv
gesehen was sie leisten banana republic
über youtube fragt wurde ein vier wochen
locker und bis mitte ende april helfen
und dann um dann ab mai wieder normaler
leben zu können
das ungefähr das zeitfenster was man
einkalkulieren müsste vier wochen in der
tat und ich will dich jetzt früh in den
lockdown gehen würden dann würden diese
vier wochen ausreichen das wäre ja nicht
also das was wir hier vor centenaire
wenig später anfangen dann kriegen wir
es umso schlechter beherrschenden damals
umso länger aber wenn wir noch vier
wochen quasi jetzt tatsächlich die
kontakte begrenzen
dann hätten wir mehrere möglichkeiten
die wir dann vorbereiten können danach
steigt ihm vater nicht an
wir könnten auf die testungen schule und
in den betrieben gut vorbereiten das
wäre ein segen also tatsächlich das
fenster was jetzt noch einmal zu
schließen wäre wenn wir den opfern
einigermaßen konsequent jetzt
durchführen wollen wir haben noch einmal
ungefähr vier wochen das ist die
größenordnung über den man ja denken
muss er um das vielleicht gerade auch
noch einmal aufzugreifen weil das auch
immer wieder an uns herangetragen wird
also die tatsache dass die institute
zahlen im moment so stark steigen hat
nicht damit zu tun dass mehr getestet
wird oder immer wie besteht da der
zusammenhang gibt es da ein mann also
kann tatsächlich ausrechnen wie viel
also incidents anwächst einfach schlicht
mehr grad und der tatsache geschuldet
ist dass die gefährlichere und
ansteckende variante jetzt um sich
greift b17 wie viel also auch das testen
zurückgeht und wie viel auf die
lockerung so geht das kann man mit also
regressionsanalyse kann man versuchen
das abzuschätzen und der anteil der
tatsächlich also auf das zusätzliche
testen zurückgeht da liegt bei höchstens
einem 600 zunahme der gesamte sident und
da er in größten teil macht tatsächlich
aus sowie zunahme der gefährlichere
mutation aus an sechs ungefähr was man
halt so berechnung heraus die lockungen
die wir gehabt haben und als sechster
das zusätzliche testen das aber das ende
der fahnenstange somit 56 und haben mit
dem zusätzlichen testen nichts zu tun ja
wunderbar dass auch noch mal also nicht
wunderbar aber gut dass man das noch mal
so konkret auch eben jetzt von ihnen
erfährt also wieder die verteilung ist
bzw
woraus die zahlen auch resultieren
matteo walter über youtube herr
lauterbach schaffen wir es dann bis zum
sommer 70 prozent zu impfen sie hatten
dadurch schon glaube ich grob skizziert
aber jetzt mal die konkrete frage bis
zum sommer 70 prozent realistisch nein
das glaube ich nicht ich glaube dass wir
etwa 50 prozent der bürger also bis zum
sommer inneren können wenn der sommer so
definiert ist dass das auto anfang juli
ist endlich juni anfang juli dann werden
wir die erster bürger vergeben zu haben
natürlich wenn wir glück haben können
wäre etwas mehr zumindest mit der
erstimpfung versehen aber vielmehr kann
es nicht sein
trotzdem ist es richtig was
bundeskanzlerin merkel gesagt hat dass
also wir bis zum september die gesamten
impfwilligen geben dann können und das
ist die zielmarke aber bis zum sommer
kann es auf jeden fall gelingt also bis
anfang juli endlich kann das uns auf
jeden fall gelingen die risikogruppen
die ersten drei risikogruppen zu impfen
und das ist das wichtigste für den das
erinnern von fotozellen das also dass
der zeithorizont bis sommer jetzt steht
aber erstmal ostern vor der tür und da
sind die aussichten nun eher trübe auch
da haben sie gesagt sind sie gegen
reisen
die frage die sich vielleicht stellen
könnte es was ist falsch daran wenn man
jetzt mit der eigenen familie verreist
im eigenen auto eine ferienwohnung
beispielsweise warum erhöhe ich damit
irgendwie das infektionsgeschehen
zunächst allein die reise selbst das
risiko und darf sich dass man sich
infiziert wenn da eine person aus dem
fahrzeug angesteckt ist da infizierte
alle anderen längeren autofahrt mit dem
wagen setzen aber bei den 1000 also wenn
jetzt mit der bahn gelassen dann sind
die züge voll also dann ist man vor ort
trifft man auf andere familien nach
unterhält sich man wird ja nicht nur
wandern wo also das wird auch
geselligkeit gibt das sind alles
zusätzliche kontakte und somit ist es
leider so je mehr kontakte wir haben
desto stärker stark gefahr sagen das hat
sich immer wieder erwiesen
nicht nur in deutschland sondern auch
international und die zahl der kontakte
die man hat dich steigt hat schlichten
ergreifen wenn man sich mit den kunden
die nicht zueinander gehören und das
reisen hat eine ganz eklige gelegenheit
über das ich warnte besonders vor als
die jetzt in die richtige gebiete wie
zum beispiel auch die balearen gehen
weil dort liegt das risiko erst mal als
niedrig gilt
sind dort quasi die begrenzungen also
die einschränkungen viel weniger
ausgeprägt als bei uns also der luft
gilt das eben nicht in die haben
somit ist das infektionsrisiko sehr hoch
da kann man sich auch infizieren die
mutationen die wir in deutschland bisher
gott sei dank noch nicht so viel haben
die südafrikanischen die brasilianische
und wenn wir das dann zurück nach
deutschland fragen wer das also
tatsächlich sehr dramatisch war das auch
bereits infizierte oder also den
früheren der ersten welle gehabt haben
oder wie es sind noch andere gefährdet
daher plädiere ich für also die testung
zumindest all jene die aus dem ausland
gemacht haben
rückkehrer ohne testo wenn sie das
machen würden würden wir anderen fehler
wiederholen den wir im letzten sommer
schon mal gemacht haben weil sie die
mutationen auch gerade angesprochen
haben wie viel sorge haben sie denn nach
wie vor vor diesen varianten was sind
ihre erkenntnisse ihrer jüngsten dazu
wie unsere impfstoffe bislang mit dem
zurechtkommen
die impfstoffe sind deutlich reduziert
[Musik]
davon aus wenn uns allein an den
antikörper mengen ist die also durch die
impfung dann entstehen also die
neutralisation der antikörper dann muss
man sagen sind die impfungen die wir
jetzt im feld haben derweil und ergeben
stoff der moderne einem stoff der
johnson johnson den stoff dreht
demnächst kommt und der erste eigentlich
sind allesamt mit der wirksamkeit
deutlich abgeschwächt das ist sogar
fraglich ob der astra ein stoff
überhaupt gegen die also südafrikanische
variante schutz bringt wie ich darf man
dann noch erkannt wenn man trotzdem sich
infiziert das weiß man nicht aber was
ist tatsächlich also so dass die
insbesondere die brasilianische
mutationen aber auch die südafrikanische
oder gar die wahnsinnig mutation wäre
wahrscheinlich die gefährlichste
überhaupt weil sie verbindet einfach
einmal in aspekte der britischen und das
ist afrikanischen und ist somit sowohl
ansteckender als auch also weniger gut
beherrschbar zu geben unknown user über
youtube schreibt österreich testet ein
viertel seiner bevölkerung in der woche
ich kann jetzt gerade nicht
kontrollieren ob das stimmt
warum schaffen wir das nicht wir haben
auch bei den tests also relativ spät in
den aufbau der test kapazität investiert
und einen lock down den wir jetzt noch
anders machen würde würde uns die
möglichkeit geben die testung in den
schulen und in den betrieben gut
vorzubereiten jetzt nach hinten zu
blicken weshalb nicht mehr des
kapazitäten da ist das bringt nichts
nach vorne geblickt wir können diese
test kapazität schnell aufbauen
einkaufen
wir müssen aber die schulen besonders
vorgehen insbesondere der aufbau der
testungen in den schulen muss absolute
priorität haben
vielleicht können sie das gerade nochmal
generell erklären also welche säule
sozusagen oder welchen stellenwert haben
testungen insgesamt jetzt in ihrem
konzept gegen die pandemie neben
impfungen also das konzept was ich
richtig wenn da wäre zunächst einmal
dass man sich ehrlich macht und sagt
ohne anderen lockt dann schaffen wir es
nicht das wachstum ist das exponentielle
wachstum stimmt einfach nicht ohne dass
wir noch einmal die maßnahmen in london
maßnahmen die wir haben verschärfen
es sollte es also diese erst in 15 wo
immer möglich in der dritten welle kann
sie vorgezogene erstimpfung das maximale
in der wahl zwischen erster und zweiter
im 50 und 80.000 14.000 menschen leben
retten in der dritten welle
das haben simulationsrechnungen von jörg
portmann wenn meier und nie auch nur
einmal verlegt und das ist die zweite
soll diese soll jetzt quasi das test
konzept und dieses konzert in schulen
und intrigen kann den erwert tatsächlich
in der größenordnung einmal zweimal pro
woche so systematisch kann das den rwe
so ungefähr 0,4 senkt und da der erwerb
der mutationen derzeit etwa 1,3 liegt
käme dann mal zimmermann dann ungefähr
war 0,9 aus den exponentiellen wachstum
mehr hauses wäre sehr sehr bedeutsam das
kann man überhaupt nicht durchsetzen und
zusätzlich also müssen wir eben durchaus
die begrenzung von reis und pokalsieger
rückkehrer testung müssen wir verhindern
dass wir also dass wir die pferde
komponente dann dass ihr mutationen
bekommen wo die wo uns die impfungen
nicht so gut
helfen wie das jetzt bei der
ursprungsplan 7 war ja der fall gilt das
was ich jetzt gerade über die test
gesagt haben für alle arten von tests
gleichermaßen also auch für die die ich
selber anwenden kann
das geht es denn selbst es auch dass
selbst wenn gemacht wird unter anleitung
in den schulen oder in den betrieben ist
von der sensitivität und spezifität
ausreichend gut um damit die bei diesen
neuen insbesondere bei der seit sieben
gefürchteten cluster zu entdecken und
den klostergarten dazu bringen somit ja
die selbst test- und auch die anti gen
test die durch schritte gemacht werden
wird in die gleichermaßen gut
wir gucken immer noch mit einem auge auf
das kanzleramt und warten ob es denn da
zu neuen entwicklungen kommt zu
irgendwelchen bewegungen aber im moment
ist das noch nicht der fall wir haben
aber gerade den hinweis bekommen dass
das in kürze der fall sein soll also es
gibt hoffnung aber einstweilen können
wir auch gerne mit ihnen noch weiter
sprechen ich tue das sehr gerne
herr lauterbach wie sieht das aus was
würden sie denn sagen wir hatten gerade
über die mutationen gesprochen und
darüber dass man natürlich eben auch mit
dem herkömmlichen impfstoff zwar noch
agieren kann dass der aber deutlich
weniger wirksam sein könnte ist er nicht
auch noch mit weiteren mutationen zu
reden also inwieweit ist das nicht doch
wieder dann grund zur sorge also es ist
schwierig immer den grund zur sorge vor
zu sagen aber tatsächlich gibt es dann
laborexperimente die nahelegen dass es
nicht die letzten mutation sein werden
den also drei mit denen wir zwingen die
britische mutation eben dann die
südafrikanische und die brasilianische
sind unterzogen die auch im labor
relativ früh entstehen aber sind weitere
mutationen ihr durchweg denkbar die und
nach wurden auch entstehen eine solche
sie sind im anlauf besitzen wenn man so
will sind new york entstand wir werden
immer wieder die impfstoffe anpassen und
müssen das ganz klar und dann mag es
vielleicht gelingen was sie dann mit den
nährstoffen die schweren infektionen
verhindern aber vielleicht nicht jede
infektion und
wir haben also sicherlich nicht
miteinander zu rechnen dass man nach
zehn jahren zurückblickt und sagt okay
es gab zuerst denn wer fühlt man dann
gab es noch drei mutationen nämlich die
englische die auslosung afrikanische und
die basel gar nicht ist das war's dann
für weitere mutationen bewegen
das wird auch insgesamt ein ähnliches
problem willst dann und misereor
verloren ja und diese anpassungen eben
auch beim impfstoff die sind auch
möglich also das ist jetzt nicht so dass
man da vor unlösbaren aufgaben steht das
vielleicht gerade noch mal von ihnen als
mut machendes zeichen also das ist schon
machbar auch da eben die von ihnen
gesprochen in anspruch ja auf jeden fall
möglich und was ihr das problem ist wir
müssen wirklich produktionskapazitäten
auf war dass wir zu jedem zeitpunkt
diese impfungen darf auch produzieren
können
in zukunft wird es immer so sein dass
die entwicklung von impfstoffen
schneller gehen als die eigentliche
produktion von impfstoffen
daher müssen wir auch als land in der
lage sagt zu jedem zeitpunkt neue
impfstoff weder für kürzeste zeit also
in entsprechender menge für die gesamte
bevölkerung produzieren zu können
lauterbach ich kriege geradeaus oder ist
es wohl noch fünf bis zehn minuten
dauern wird bis die kanzlerin vor die
presse tritt wollten sie die zeit noch
hätten wäre ich sehr dankbar sie würden
sie noch mit uns verbringen wir hatten
jetzt gerade gesprochen über die virus
mutationen lassen sie uns vielleicht
auch noch mal über die impfstoffe
sprechen was ist denn aus ihrer sicht
zum beispiel auch mit dem russischen
präparat sputnik wie wir hatten vorhin
schon den bundesgesundheitsminister dazu
gehört und auch die einschätzung von
frau otto wie ist ihre meinung dazu
sollte man den dazu nehmen der russische
impfstoff hat was die wirkung angeht man
das auch wer prinzip angeht bisher sehr
überzeugt das muss man einfach einräumen
das ist kein schlechter ist oft ganz im
gegenteil
auf der anderen seite ist es schwer denn
die europäische zulassung es habe ich ja
noch nicht andere beantragt und es gab
auch ein paar ungereimtheiten in der
publikation was die zahl der
nebenwirkungen angeht die war
unrealistisch niedrig und daher also
kann man zum jetzigen zeitpunkt leider
nicht sagen wann der impfstoff in europa
zugelassen wird
ich glaube aber dass also der eben doch
besser sein
und ich könnte mir gut vorstellen dass
dieser ebenfalls eine rolle spielen das
ist eigentlich schade dass er also nicht
so sauberer und klarer hier vorgetragen
worte ohne analysiert wurde
was ich für sehr interessant ist dass
man einfach prüft auf der kinderstation
menschen so ob der vielleicht nicht über
ein beschleunigtes verfahren zugelassen
werden kann
anregungen wie man sie bloß immer dort
prüft weil er ist eine art und war so
wie er wird sehr ähnlich den wald gehen
und aus dem moderner impfstoff und hier
könnte man eine zulassung erwägen also
die phase 3 studie die man üblicherweise
braucht wo die übersprungen wird und wo
man einfach an hier an die koffer
bildung und an der immunreaktion des
impfstoffes auf mich minute hennigsdorf
ist ich glaube dann könnte man diese
nämlich schneller zu lassen und so
ähnlich zu lassen die weiterentwicklung
von impfstoffen die global zu haben
wir wollen gerne hin und wieder die
vielleicht für den einen oder anderen
etwas trockene materie der impfstoffe
oder überhaupt der medizinischen
erläuterungen verlassen in sozialen
netzwerken ist nämlich manche sie
während der bessere gesundheitsminister
ist das jetzt der plan für den herbst
sozusagen er lauterbach laut so aus ich
mich gar nicht darüber spekuliere ich
gar nicht und gesagt ich verstehe mich
mit mit jens spahn gut wir arbeiten gut
zusammen und mir ist natürlich zu sagen
gut also die hochschätzung hochachtung
für den kollegen vielleicht gerade dann
doch mal an der stelle die frage ja ob
sie da sie ja doch eben relativ
regelmäßig in der rolle des mahners
auftreten ärgert auch dass wurde an uns
herangetragen über die sozialen medien
wenn die länderchefs oder chefinnen oder
vielleicht auch sogar die kanzlerin
nicht auf ihre ratschläge hören wohnt
sie das persönlich nein es geht hier
nicht darum was mich persönlich also
trifft oder nicht also ich sehe diese
dinge immer nur aus der perspektive der
bevölkerung und also hier geht es
wirklich nicht um mich und also ob ich
mir etwas gut oder schlecht die wir uns
weiter sondern also ich versuche einfach
vorstellte zu machen nach bestem wissen
und gewissen und stelle mich darüber
dass mit anderen wissenschaftlern sehr
eng
ab das ist ein team also theoretiker
hier also vorher nicht und ich nehme
auch wieder kritik gerne an aber ich
glaube das gilt da spreche ich für alle
mit denen ich da zusammenarbeite und es
geht einfach nur um die sache um mehr
nicht
vielleicht ist gerade auch nochmal weil
sie auch von kritik sprechen es ist auch
eine viel geäußerte kritik dass die
bundesregierung relativ einseitig sich
beraten lässt in diesem lockdown in
dieser pandemie zeit und dass die
medizinischen stimmen sehr stark
berücksichtigt werden dass aber andere
zum beispiel soziale gesichtspunkte um
nur ein beispiel zu nennen
weniger beachtung finden gerade sie sind
natürlich jemand der sich unter anderem
auch öfter schon für locker uns
ausgesprochen hat wie nehmen sie das
wahr fühlen sie sich da auch falsch
wahrgenommen falsch dargestellt wie ist
ihr blick auf die situation insgesamt
denn der wird ja nicht nur medizinisch
sein
ja ja auch alles war und ich zum
beispiel finde es ganz schrecklich wie
ich schlecht unsere kinder durch diese
krise bisher gekommen sind weil da war
viel mehr möglich und ich würde zwar
immer als mister lockdown und
dergleichen auch ein bisschen aus dem
von dem einen oder anderen verspottet
aber was ist ja auch so das gehört auch
zu wald dazu dass mich sehr früh dafür
eingesetzt habe dass die luft fehlt
anlagen für dich ruhe sorgen dass wir
die kinder regelmäßig mit anti gen test
versorgen sodass wir fuhren sicher
bezahlen können dass wir wechseln
unterricht und also besseres
homeschooling vorbereiten
ich glaube wir haben den kippern
wirklich viel zu viel zugemutet in
dieser taten eben das tut mir sehr weh
das merke ich auch an meine eigenen 14
jährigen dort hätte ich noch zur schule
geht es ja genau und also von daher bin
ich also hier auch mit betroffenen
blendet das nicht aus und viele freunde
von mir arbeiten in der psychiatrie
so also absolut therapeuten oder und ich
bekomme natürlich diese seite selbst
mich auch voll mit gespielt das ist
keine frage es geht mir nicht ich war es
überhaupt daraufhin auch in der
regierungsarbeit sind die sozialen
aspekte immer mitlaufen franziska aviv
alberto zahlt das sind einfach leute die
denken diese soziale komponente an die
zeit mit wir tauschen uns aus
somit das zu begrenzen also nach dem
motto es geht ihr nur
dass theologen und epidemiologin wollen
und das ist falsch und so läuft es auch
in wirklichkeit gar nicht
also wir machen eine arbeit als team und
das spielen die anderen aspekte eine
genauso große rolle
und die werden auch weiterhin eine große
rolle spielen nehme ich an auch in der
zeit jetzt nach dem vielleicht wir
werden es gleich erfahren dann wieder
bevorstehenden lockdown haben sie da
vielleicht auch hoffnungen die sie
machen können dass sie sagen ja also in
der zukunft werden auch diese soziale
aspekte stärker berücksichtigt die jetzt
nach ihren äußerungen schon zwar
berücksichtigt wurden auch in der
vergangenheit aber dass die eben auch
dann ab april ab mal wieder stärker
gewicht bekommen dass man nach
möglichkeit nicht wieder in so einen
harten locker und zurück musste eben
diese negativen folgen mit sich bringen
würde
also wir sind jetzt ohnedies wir sind
jetzt unsere dies im letzten wirklich
großem bedauern dass es gar keine frage
weil durch die kombination text um
impfung besseres wetter
wenn wir es noch einmal runterbringen
dann haben wir natürlich auch was frei
wollen wir gewonnen die wir sonst nicht
hätten
und in dieser zeit also müssen wir also
schauen dass sie diesen kinder und so
schnell wie möglich die schule wieder
wirklich machen das ist das wichtigste
das muss im vordergrund stehen und dann
muss man auch also vor der illusion
warnen dass das möglich wäre auch ohne
flächendeckende testung
ich persönlich habe es als sehr misslich
und problematische freunde dass wir die
aus antiken tests hoher qualität
ich war sie in den supermärkten verkauft
haben und sie dort sofort im sommer in
den markt gegangen sind zum teil also
auch unnütz seien eingesetzt worden sind
und die kinder haben es sehr nicht
bekommen hochschulen wird nicht getestet
das ist nicht die richtige priorität
die über youtube pardon erfragt uns die
psychischen folgen für die gesellschaft
sind so immens hoch bis hin zu einer
herdenimmunität dauert es noch lange
wäre es für die allgemeinheit
angemessener anzufangen mit dem virus zu
leben was auch immer
sich der oder diejenige jetzt genau
darunter vorstellt also mit dem virus
leben das ist in gewisser weise eine
floskel ist das nicht also wenn wir wenn
das gemeint ist mit dem bios leben das
weg ohne lockten die menschen quasi also
der infektion überlassen dann ist das
einfach schlicht völlig indiskutabel
das hat sicher und erwiesen und das
sollten epidemiologen schon relativ früh
für deutschland berechnet dass wir
gemessen an der zahl der infizierten
eine sterblichkeit von einem prozent und
wir haben das alles hätte man hier keine
lockt uns gemacht und man hätte mit dem
virus gelesen dieb sinne dass wir hat
langsam die bevölkerung der solchen fall
gegeben hätten dann wären bis zu 500.000
menschen gestorben
das ist einfach nicht vollkommen
unakzeptabel das hat uns auch kein land
erwogen oder gemacht wovon drei man kann
mit einem so virus dieser gefährlich gar
nicht leben
das ist so gut wie ich mir auch
ernsthaft einen krieger als haustier
halten kann man kann ja nicht sagen ich
kann muss jetzt lernen mit dem flieger
zu leben das ist entweder kommt der
täter aus der erholung aus oder
irgendwann ein interessantes bild das
sie da gezeichnet haben vielleicht noch
mal den blick über die grenzen
deutschlands hinaus gewartet denn ich
meine die pandemie ist natürlich ein ein
weltweites problem also selbst wenn wir
jetzt in deutschland und ich verstehe
dass wir jetzt natürlich in erster linie
darauf schauen aber jetzt bald mit dem
virus ganz gut umgehen können inwieweit
müssen wir dann nicht trotzdem auch
sorge dafür tragen dass in anderen
teilen der welt vielleicht weniger
entwickelten auch genau das gleiche
stattfindet dass wir uns also eben in
deutschland trotzdem also eben auch
deswegen sicher fühlen können weil das
virus weltweit auch entsprechend
angegangen wird
ja das ist tatsächlich von allergrößter
bedeutung weil im labor sieht man ganz
genau die fragen haben wir eben schon
mal auf das ist bei diesen mutationen
die wir jetzt zu haben größte attraktion
die wir jetzt haben die briten das
südafrikanischen und auf der
brasilianischen nicht bleiben es wird
einfach weitergehen das wird noch mehr
motivation geht und die entstehen dann
nicht in den ländern wo schon geimpft
wurde
sollen wir entstehen dann in den ländern
wo noch nicht gegeben wurde
das virus ist sehr schnell verbreiten
kann
das kann bedeuten dass diese mutationen
dann für die bereits geimpften eine
große rolle spielen sagen quasi
zurückkommen auf die europäischen länder
somit also wir müssen hier aus drei
gründen die menschen impfen
die aus lehrern oder den liegen zum
einen weil es diese menschen auf beträgt
auch während schicksal ist uns wichtig
wir können nicht so egoistisch sein und
gehen selbst schon in die zweite oder
dritte im keller der war diese menschen
noch nie gegeben worden sind
mal müssen wir diese menschen auch
irgendwann mal dort ist großes leid und
die menschen die dort erkannten können
sie gar nicht gut versorgt werden das
ist auch so manche therapien zum zweiten
mutationen kommen zurück und diese
mutationen sind dann auch für uns von
großer bedeutung und zum dritten mann
muss auf die ökologischen folgen
bedenken oder so wenn die länder die
ärmer drin also nicht langsam aus einer
situation kommen zu ihr weigelt alltag
wieder zurückzukommen dann hat das
gravierende folgen für die gesamte welt
und das fängt damit an dass derzeit in
den armen ländern dieser welt die kinder
zum teil seit sehr langer zeit nicht
mehr regulär die schule besuchen können
also dass wir gesagt auch ein großes
problem wir sind immer noch herr
lauterbach bei dem blick aufs kanzleramt
aber wir sehen im wald und hat leider
immer noch keine bundeskanzlerin sie
heben bitte die hand wenn sie nicht mehr
können aber solange sie noch da sind
würde ich sie gerne noch als mein
gesprächspartner behalten
wenn wir jetzt noch mal schauen auf die
lage in deutschland werden jetzt gerade
den blick etwas geweitet aber auf die
lage in deutschland dann würde ich sie
gerne noch mal fragen also wie sehen sie
da jetzt momentan uns aufgestellt
vielleicht wenn es noch mal kurz
zusammenfassen würden wie wir jetzt
durch die nächsten wochen kommen sollten
sie hatten gerade schon mal skizziert
also der lock down ist ganz wichtig dann
aber eben vor allem dass auch die
impfungen kommen und die testung ist das
so das paket mit dem wir jetzt durch die
nächsten wochen kommen werden sollten
ich hoffe ich hoffe also wie gesagt das
paket was ich empfehlen würde es dass
man sich ehrlich macht wir brauchen noch
mal einen dorfladen um aus dem
exponentiellen wachstum herauszukommen
wir müssen beim impfen die erstimpfung
vollziehen weil die erstimpfung geben
den größten teil des schutzes bringt so
vielen menschen wie möglich die erste
impfung geben mit einem gespalten in
winter wahl zwischen der ersten und der
zweiten impfung und zum sollten dass man
in der zeit wo der lok dann noch gilt
die testungen in den schulen und den
betrieb und zweimal pro woche
evidenzbasiert vorsieht und zum vierten
eben reisen so gut wie möglich
fernhalten und die reiserückkehrer zu
testen wenn sie aus nach deutschland
zurückkehren
mit diesen vier massnahmen würde ich
versuchen nächsten woche zu den nächsten
wochen zu überbrücken wenn man das also
ein paar wochen durchhält beispielsweise
in der größenordnung von vier wochen
dann kommen wir aus meiner sicht also so
schnell in ein hohes im vorhinein und
können das auch flächendeckend gästen
dass wir quasi dann sicher in den sommer
hinein kommen ja das sind doch mut
machende worte und ich danke ihnen ganz
herzlich professor karl lauterbach für
dieses gespräch dass sie sich so lange
zeit für uns genommen haben danke schön
alles gute noch einmal nach berlin und
wir bleiben in berlin zwar immer noch
nicht im kanzleramt aber bei unserer
hauptstadt korrespondent in bioshock und
allah deiner de genau denn ich habe
gehört es gibt schon etwas zu vermelden
und allah was weiß man bislang ja es
geht jetzt so das ein oder andere durch
markus söder zum beispiel ist schon sehr
schnell gewesen und hat schon seine
freude darüber getwittert dass es für
die hotspots in den grenzregionen in
bayern zusätzliche impfstoffe geben soll
vor allem um die mutanten abzuwehren da
gibt es 100.000 impfdosen zusätzlich
allein für bayern hat er wohl getwittert
und das gilt auch für weitere vier
bundesländer das war in dem entwurf
schon vorgesehen dass besonders
betroffene grenzregionen die sich in
nachbarschaft zu gefährlichen zu
gebieten mit den gefährlichen potenten
mutanten befinden noch mal extra
impfdosen bekommen sondern es sind jetzt
insgesamt 5 länder bundesländern neben
bayern das saarland sachsen thüringen
und auch rheinland pfalz rheinland pfalz
auch im grenzgebiet zu frankreich hat
und da sieht es eben
an der einen oder anderen stelle
momentan nicht so besonders gut aus und
was wir auch schon hören ist das
tatsächlich der plan angenommen worden
ist die hausärzte und betriebsärzte
früher einzubinden als geplant nämlich
schon nach ostern anfang april ab dem
fünften april soll es losgehen
man muss aber sagen dass es
wahrscheinlich nur sehr langsam dort
losgehen wird denn im beschluss in der
vorlage stand auch drin
das wird erstmals muss ich gerade mal
nachschauen auf meinen zettel 50.000
praxen zu beginn betreffen die sollen
dann pro woche so viele impfdosen
bekommen dass jede praxis 20 impfdosen
hat und jetzt sehe ich gerade die
kanzlerin kommt und dann immer noch rein
und regierungschefinnen der bundesländer
über die deutsche impfkampagne gegen das
koma virus beraten
wir hatten diese telefonkonferenz ja
eigentlich schon für mittwoch verabredet
mussten sie aber verlegen um die
entscheidung der ema zur weiteren
nutzung des astra zeneca impfstoffs
abzuwarten und sie bei unseren heutigen
beratungen auch wirklich berücksichtigen
zu können
nach der gestrigen entscheidung der
europäischen medizin agentur hatten wir
dann heute die notwendige klarheit und
konnten loslegen
es ging darum die nächste phase unserer
impfkampagne ab april zu planen und mit
den aktuell drei zur verfügung stehenden
impfstoffen astrazeneca biontech und
moderner und in einigen wochen dann auch
mit johnson & johnson dem vierten
impfstoffs haben wir ja eine gute
grundlage das ziel unserer heutigen
beratung war klar wir wollen und ab
april können wir das auch schneller und
flexibler werden
wir wollen dass auch hier die
sprichwörtliche und im übrigen auch
bewährte deutsche gründlichkeit um mehr
deutsche flexibilität ergänzt wird
wir wollen erreichen dass wir ab dem
zweiten quartal so schnell wie möglich
so flexibel
wie möglich mit dem impfen in
deutschland vorankommen
die devise lautet impfen impfen
und deshalb haben wir heute ein konzept
vereinbart mit dem neben den so
wichtigen impfzentren und die ärzte
sanitäter und logistischen mitarbeiter
dort leisten wirklich großartiges neben
denen wollen wir immer mehr auch die
niedergelassenen ärzte an den impfungen
beteiligen
dabei geht es uns nicht um entweder oder
sondern um sowohl als auch und deshalb
haben wir intensiv darüber beraten wie
wir beides impfzentren und arztpraxen
schnellstmöglich kombinieren und
unbürokratisch arbeiten können also
kombinieren auf der einen seite und
unbürokratisch vorangehen und zu keiner
sekunde natürlich aus dem auge verlieren
dass wir denen die unseren ganz
besonderen schutz brauchen auch
weiterhin diesen ganz besonderen schutz
geben und auf dieser grundlage haben wir
folgendes beschlossen dabei war uns
natürlich die empfehlung der
gesundheitsministerkonferenz von vor
wenigen tagen auch leitfaden werden
beschlossen dass die etablierten
strukturen der impfzentren und mobilen
impf teams weiterhin natürlich benötigt
werden und mit einem sockel von
mindestens oder wöchentlich 22 5
millionen dosen beliefert werden das ist
also der sockel denen die impfzentren
verlässlich bekommen
die aufteilung dieser impfstoffe erfolgt
weiterhin gemäß bevölkerungsanteil und
die menge der pro woche verfügbaren
impfstoffe die die wöchentliche
lieferung an die impfzentren der länder
übersteigt wird ab der 14
kalenderwoche das ist also die woche
nach ostern gemäss bevölkerungsanteil
der länder an die arztpraxen
ausgeliefert und dort routinemäßig
verimpft es geht um die hausarztpraxen
und für die impfungen in arztpraxen gilt
die priorisierung gemäß der korona
impfverordnung ebenfalls als
lage sie kann aber flexibel an gesendet
werden die fakten sind zu beginn
aufgefordert natürlich vor allen dingen
im mobile patientinnen und patienten in
eigenen häuslichkeit sowie personen mit
vorerkrankungen die mit einem hohen
risiko behaftet sind natürlich zuerst zu
impfen
und wir müssen darauf hinweisen wir
wollen ja schnell in diesem übergang zu
den arztpraxen das bedeutet aber auch
dass die lieferung bei der großen zahl
von hausarztpraxen nämlich etwa 50.000
am anfang noch pro praxis recht gering
sein werden also etwa 20 impfdosen pro
praxis das heißt also das wird sich erst
langsam aufbauen
aber wir glauben dass es wichtig ist
jetzt anzufangen
die gesundheitsminister das begrüßen wir
ausdrücklich haben festgelegt dass der
dokumentationsaufwand so gering wie
möglich gehalten werden soll
einzelne länder können gegenüber dem
bundesministerium für gesundheit bis
montag eine opt out erklärung abgeben
das würde dann bedeuten dass die
apotheken dieses landes nicht vom
pharmazeutischen großhandel beliefert
werden aber ich kann ihnen jetzt schon
sagen dass die übergroße mehrheit der
länder auf jeden fall mit dem beschluss
den wir heute gefasst hat also den
übergang auch zusätzlich zu den
impfzentren zu den arztpraxen mitgehen
wird sodann haben wir uns noch mit einem
zweiten phänomen befasst und das ist die
tatsache dass wir eine zusätzliche
lieferung bekommen von der europäischen
union bei und eckpfeiler kann
im erstem ende des ersten quartals noch
einmal 4 millionen für europa mehr
liefern als eigentlich veranschlagt
waren und die kommission hatte er schon
darauf hingewiesen dass hier vor allen
dingen grenznahe regionen und regionen
mit besonderen mutationen speziell
berücksichtigt werden sollen
nun haben wir in der diskussion der
länder natürlich auch herausgearbeitet
dass eigentlich jedes bundesland auch
seinen hot spot hat aber wir haben uns
auch folgendes einigen können dafür bin
ich sehr dankbar
es werden angesichts der
südafrikanischen
mutationen die vor allen dingen aus
frankreich aus der region mosel kommen
und wegen des sehr hohen pendler
aufkommens von pendlern die inländischen
und auch einer technischen betrieben
arbeiten werden dem saarland 80.000
zusätzliche dosen und rheinland-pfalz
20.000 zusätzliche dosen bereitgestellt
und wir berücksichtigen diejenigen der
einen sehr starken pendler bezug zu der
tschechischen republik haben
das sind die länder bayern sachsen und
thüringen wo bayern und sachsen jeweils
100.000 dosen zusätzlich bekommen und
30.000 dosen dann nach thüringen gehen
wir werden die restlichen dosen zu den
580.000 losen die insgesamt zur
verfügung stehen dann in die erste
lieferung an die arztpraxen mit
einfließen lassen so dass wir dann für
die arztpraxen zu beginn etwa eine
million dosen haben und daraus ergibt
sich dann eben auch die durchschnitte
dosis pro arztpraxis von etwa 20 von
etwa 20 dosen pro woche die angaben sind
immer pro woche was jetzt die arztpraxen
anbelangt wir haben diese diesen extra
im kippte heute also erfolgreich
abgeschlossen es war eine gute sachliche
diskussion ich glaube alle sind sehr
motiviert auf beiden säulen aufbauend
auf dem soll auf der säule im zentrum
und auf der säule arztpraxen jetzt auch
loszulegen
ich habe in dieser woche eine video
konferenz auch mit dem präsidenten der
kassenärztlichen vereinigung gehabt mit
herrn gassen und wir haben dort auch die
details durch gesprochen denn natürlich
können die arztpraxen sehr viel mehr als
20 dosen pro arztpraxis in der woche für
impfen dazu sind sie auch bereit und das
wird auch aufwachsen aber wir glauben
dass es der flexibilität schnelligkeit
aber auch der erreichbarkeit von
personen die
in besonderer notlage sind dient wenn
wir die arztpraxen jetzt mit einbeziehen
dies war heute der impf gipfel am montag
findet die nächste
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz statt da
werden wir die fortsetzung dessen
beraten was wir in aussicht gestellt
haben bei unserer konferenz am dritten
märz
und hier will ich nur als ausblick sagen
ohne den beschlüssen vor greifen zu
können dass die situation sicher sehr
schwierig entwickelt wir sehen jeden tag
steigende incident zahlen wir haben ein
exponentielles wachstum ein erfa cto
deutlich über 1 und sind jetzt
deutschlandweit schon sehr nahe einer
incidents von 100 so die oft gesagt
haltet euch nicht nur bei den instanzen
auf aber die inzidenz ist halt eine
wichtige größe und der faktor natürlich
noch eine wichtige größe dazu wenn er
über 1 ist wissen wir dass wir an einem
exponentiellen wachstum sind und deshalb
ist es gut dass wir eine notbremse
vereinbart hatten und wir werden leider
auch von dieser notbremse gebrauch
machen müssen wären wir damals
vereinbart steigt die sieben tage
incidents pro 100000 einwohner und
einwohner an drei aufeinanderfolgenden
tagen in einem bundesland oder einer
region auf über 100 treten dann ab dem
zweiten darauf folgenden werktag die
regeln die bis zum 7
märz gegolten haben wieder in kraft das
haben wir die notbremse genannt und ich
hätte mir gewünscht dass wir ohne diese
notbremse auskommen aber das wird nicht
möglich sein wenn ich mir die
entwicklung der letzten tage anschaue so
weit meine ausführungen zu dem heutigen
gespräch und zudem ausblick auf montag
[Musik]
vielen dank frau bundeskanzlerin
glauben sie dass sie jetzt trotz also im
hinblick auf die den zeitraum an ihrer
aussage fest halten können dass man ein
impfangebot machen kann
bis zum ende des sommers allen bürgern
trotz der schwierigkeiten die es jetzt
gab bei astrazeneca und die zweite frage
spielte das auch eine rolle dass man
einen weiteren impfstoff etwa den des
russischen herstellers also sputnik zu
lassen könnte möglicherweise auch in
einem alleingang wie es der
bundesgesundheitsminister vorgeschlagen
hat ja also ich glaube dass wir gute
chancen haben unser unsere aussage dass
wir bis zum ende des sommers jedem
bundesbürger eine aus ein angebot auf
eine möglichkeit machen können dass das
weiter einzuhalten ist wir müssen immer
davon abhängig sein was wird geliefert
und wir können immer nur die aussage
machen nachdem was planbar ist aber ich
kann sie weiter aufrechterhalten nach
dem was ich weiß und was sich ergibt
und was den russischen impfstoff
anbelangt so habe ich vertrete ich seit
geraumer zeit die meinung dass wir jeden
impfstoff der bei der europäischen
medizin agentur zugelassen wird auch
nutzen sollten innerhalb der
europäischen union ich würde eine
europäische bestellung vorziehen wenn es
zu einer solchen europäischen bestellung
nicht thema aber dafür habe ich kein
anzeichen
dann müssten wir auch einen deutschen
weg alleine gehen das ist uns dann
möglich und das würden wir dann auch tun
frau bundeskanzlerin ich noch mal
zurückkommen darf zu ihrer bemerkung mit
blick auf jetzt kommenden montag wo sie
ja sagten gut man kann auch nicht sagen
was genau beschlossen wird aber wenn es
um diese notbremse geht ist das jetzt
eigentlich wenn davon die rede ist dass
die wieder dass die verschärft werden
muss heißt das dass sie darauf drängen
werden einfach dass diese notbremse
sozusagen wirklich von allen ländern und
bezirken eingehalten wird oder werden
sie möglicherweise auch noch mal darüber
diskutieren wollen ob diese grenze
möglicherweise noch noch etwas abgesenkt
wird also fragt auf 50 auf eine inzidenz
von 50 auf 100 aber zu einigen wurde sie
auch auf 200 hochgesetzt und und denn
nur ganz ganz kurz noch würden sie sich
jetzt eigentlich mit erstrangiger impfen
lassen wenn sie an der reihe sind und
die möglichkeit hätten das ist jetzt
möglich weil das alters die altersgrenze
ja nicht mehr besteht ich würde mich mit
astrazeneca impfen lassen das habe ich
schon öfter gesagt ich möchte aber
warten bis ich dran bin aber ich würde
das auf jeden fall tun und ich habe hier
die notbremse noch einmal in erinnerung
gerufen weil sie ja teil unserer
beschlüsse ist und deshalb glaube ich
ist das ganz wichtig auch für die
verlässlichkeit unserer arbeit dass wir
unsere beschlüsse einhalten und ich
hätte mir gewünscht dass wir darüber zu
reden müssen dass wir sie anwenden
müssen aber die entwicklung ist ebenso
wie wir sie im augenblick sehen und was
jetzt weil sie noch die 200 erwähnten
das ist ja eine sonderregelung wir haben
ja ganz früher mal die super hot spots
sozusagen gehabt mit incident sind von
200 noch einmal zusätzliche massnahmen
gemacht werden müssen zu dem was
insgesamt gilt aber es war ja schon ein
kompromiss die spanne zwischen 50 und
100 zu nehmen und bei der überschreitung
der 100 und
die einfach auch der tatsache dass es
nicht sinkende zahlen sind also wenn wir
jetzt mein ding vor zwei wochen bei 110
gewesen wären und wir werden jetzt
runter gegangen auf 89 dann wäre es eine
andere situation oder auf 101 ist sogar
ein
wir sind stark aber in einem ebenfalls
exponentiell ansteigenden entwicklung
und diese tatsache der bedeutet dass die
notbremse natürlich von besonderer
bedeutung ist
frau bundeskanzlerin kurze nachfrage
jetzt zu der sie sagten sie würden sich
mit astrazeneca impfen lassen
es entstand ein großer schaden für für
diesen impfstoff viele sind sehr
vorsichtig halten sie es nicht für eine
gute idee dass die bundes dass die
mitglieder der bundesregierung sie
inklusive doch etwas früher sich impfen
lassen
also erstmal möchte ich sagen ich
bezweifle das ein großer schaden
entstand sondern alle diese impfstoffe
haben eine bedingte zulassung laufe
dieser bedingten zulassung sammeln wir
zum ersten mal erfahrung was passiert
wenn es dieser impfstoff für millionen
von menschen angewandt wird sie wissen
die studie drei phase 3 der
impfstoffentwicklung das sind ungefähr
40.000 probanden an denen werden die
wichtigen grundlegenden erkenntnisse
gesammelt danach sind die unterlagen da
um eine solche bedingte zulassung zu
bekommen und in der phase der bedingten
zulassung eines solchen impfstoff wird
dann sehr genau überwacht deshalb wird
es ja auch alles so spezifisch überwacht
was kann alles an nebenwirkungen
passieren oder an fällen oder bestimmten
dingen auftreten und die europäische
medizin agentur wird ja gemeinsam auch
mit dem paul ehrlich institut weiter das
ganze über prüfen und überwachen und
wenn weitere erkenntnisse kommen kann es
auch sein dass sich die immer noch mal
damit befassen muss aber ich finde es
war richtig dass wir absolute
transparenz haben leiten lassen dass wir
das unterbrochen haben und dann die
stellungnahme der europäischen medizin
agentur abgewartet haben und auf der
basis weiß jeder dass wir nicht etwas
sozusagen hinterm berg halten etwas
nicht aussprechen was vielleicht
auffällig sein könnte sondern dass wir
wirklich die dinge transparent auf den
tisch liegen und ich glaube daraus
entsteht vertrauen und das wollen so
wollen wir auch weiter vorgehen und was
jetzt die frage der impfungen anbelangt
so würde sich eine solche frage ja nur
stellen wenn wir in der prioritäten
gruppe 1 die noch nicht mal durchgeimpft
ist oder in der prioritäten gruppe 2
jedem einen ins angebot machen und dann
immer noch astrazeneca übrig bleibt
davon sind wir aber weit entfernt
das heißt wir können nicht jetzt uns als
politiker impfen lassen obwohl
vielleicht menschen darauf warten und
die sich gerne mit astrazeneca impfen
lassen wollen und deshalb stellt sich
diese frage zurzeit nicht frau
bundeskanzlerin jetzt kann man sich ja
leider nicht physisch treffen oder nur
bedingt wegen corona aber die form der
video konferenz hat sich ja eigentlich
jetzt etabliert im laufe der letzten
monate über die gipfel hinweg und
deswegen die frage warum ist man heute
aufs telefon umgestiegen warum gab es
eine telefon schalte gab es technische
probleme oder wollte man eventuell nicht
dass man sieht wenn jemand schlümpfe
guckt oder ähnliches am montag wieder
eine video-konferenz das ist ja jetzt
praktisch ein sondertreffen zum impfen
gewesen und das hatten wir schon seit
langem als telefonkonferenz vereinbart
aber montag ist wieder video-konferenz
es scheint auch ein technisch inzwischen
einfacher zu sein manchmal als eine
telefonkonferenz finde man bei den
konferenzen erlebt also keine sorge sie
werden auch weiter videokonferenzen von
videokonferenzen hören
frau bundeskanzlerin eine detail
nachfrage sie das papier ist jetzt
ergänzt worden um den satz bei der
priorisierung dass die hausärzte das
flexibel auslegen können sie haben das
auch gerade selber erwähnt können sie
mal sagen was darunter zu verstehen ist
flexibel und dann noch eine etwas
allgemeiner politische frage ist wurde
in dieser woche aus der opposition der
vor der die forderungen werden sie
erhoben den bundesgesundheitsminister zu
entlassen
können sie sich diesen gedanken nähern
nein um die zweite frage gleich zu
beantworten und ansonsten
haben wir darüber gesprochen was
bedeutet auf der grundlage der
grundstoff verordnung und da gab es
unterschiedliche meinungen ob darin
schon flexibilität enthalten ist oder
nicht ausreichend wir wollen einfach
nicht das was dass das was manchmal in
den impfzentren jetzt passiert ist das
wenn zwei dosen übrig sind oder wenn
jemand nicht gekommen ist das dann
abends händeringend gesucht wird und man
vielleicht belangt wird wenn man den
falschen menschen etwas gibt wenn jemand
mit seinen ehepartner kommt es wird zwar
gesagt dass auch die impfverordnung
diese flexibilität schon zuletzt aber
wir wollten dann nochmal ermutigen wir
haben im übrigen tiefes vertrauen darin
dass die hausärzte wissen wer die
bedürftigsten personen sind wir am
meisten eine solche impfung braucht und
der leitfaden der leitgedanke des
impfens auch in den hausarztpraxen ist
der gleiche wie beim testzentrum nehme
ich die impfung so dann danke ich ihnen
und manch einen werden wir am montag
wieder sehr schönes wochenende
ja also soweit die bundeskanzlerin nach
den beratungen mit den
ministerpräsidenten und
ministerpräsidenten der länder das also
noch mal vielleicht in ganz kurzer
zusammenfassung das wesentliche was sie
gesagt hat die devise muss lauten impfen
impfen impfen und die hausärzte sollen
eben auch beteiligt werden und zwar
etwas früher als vielleicht schon vorher
gedacht nämlich zu ostern soll es
beziehungsweise in der kw 14 also nach
wo es dann losgehen mit eben auch der
auslieferung von impfdosen an die praxen
insgesamt 50.000 praxen gibt es in
deutschland und in einer dieser praxen
arbeitet unter anderem frau dr ulrike
guckte ich nehme ich das schon im
hintergrund sehen wir haben schon
miteinander gesprochen schön dass sie
noch mal bei uns sind frau doktor cook
also was haben sie jetzt gerade
mitgenommen aus dem was die
bundeskanzlerin gesagt hat waren sie mit
diesen ankündigungen insbesondere damit
dass eben jetzt auch demnächst die
hausärztinnen und ärzte mitmachen dürfen
zufrieden
ja es ist ja vorher schon so ein
bisschen durchgesickert dass es wohl so
aussieht dass ein bisschen mehr
impfstoff freigegeben wird wobei
wir ja den astra techniker für impfen
werden und dass es ab dem zweiten
quartal dann deutlich mehr impfstoff
gibt den wir kämpfen können
da es ja 50.000 praxen sind ist
natürlich die menge die jede einzelne
praxis dann bekommt er geringer aber in
der großen masse summiert sich das dann
wieder wenn es eben zusätzlich zu den
impfzentren bei uns eingesetzt wir haben
vielleicht ganz kurz die kanzlerin
sprach von 20 dosen roundabout pro
praxis am anfang die nachdem also am
anfang genau werden ist er noch nicht so
viele sein
ja aber das ist ja wenn man sich das in
der masse anschaut und dann zusätzlich
parallel zu den impfzentren verimpft
kann das auch also denke ich würde das
sehr sehr viel effekt bringen ja darauf
hoffen wir jedenfalls alle dass das
einen effekt bringen wird die kanzlerin
hat auch noch mal betont dass es da eine
schon etwas flexiblere handhabung geben
soll auch seitens der niedergelassenen
ärztinnen und ärzte dass man also jetzt
nicht ganz scharf darauf schaut also das
natürlich auf der einen seite die
priorisierung eingehalten werden soll
aber dass man jetzt eben nicht ganz
scharf darauf schauen ob man vielleicht
auch mal ein ehepartner noch mit geimpft
wird wenn am ende des tages vielleicht
noch was übrig ist erleichtert sie diese
ankündigung ich ja es ist macht es
natürlich so ein bisschen leichter dass
man jetzt nicht im hinterkopf haben muss
dass man vielleicht erst mal noch auf
die liste gucken muss wenn man jetzt
impfen darf und wen nicht wobei man das
ja alles schon irgendwie in das hat man
ja schon im kopf und wenn jetzt ein
hochbetagter patient pflegebedürftig ist
dann macht es natürlich auch sinn den
ehepartner die ehepartnerin gleich mit
zu impfen
letztlich gestaltet sich das für uns
dann natürlich leichter wenn wir ein ein
wenig mehr spielraum haben wobei die
priorisierung gerade der wohlener
rebellengruppen immens wichtig ist die
priorisierung der vokabel und gruppen
haben sie gerade angesprochen also das
heißt eben auch für sie das selbst wenn
sie jetzt also ein bisschen freie hand
habe haben sie trotzdem sehr danach
gehen werden wer steht auf
für uns war in welcher reihenfolge auch
ja die machen ja sinn die
priorisierungen also wir haben ja einen
schutzauftrag für unsere patienten und
da kann es dann nicht sein dass wir
einen 20-jährigen gesunden patienten
vorziehen gegenüber jemandem der voll
kranken hat und alt ist ja das leuchtet
ein frau doktor guck ich danke ihnen
ganz herzlich dass sie noch mal kurz
angeordnet haben wie sie aus der praxis
die beschlüsse bewerten was das impfen
angeht also wie gesagt ab ostern soll es
dann losgehen auch mit den hausärztinnen
und hausärzte dankeschön nochmal für
ihre meinung dazu
und wir sprechen noch mal mit unserer
korrespondentin im hauptstadtstudio mit
chuck und allah energy vielleicht auch
noch mal ganz kurz die einschätzungen
überraschendes dabei gewesen oder die
wirkte die bundeskanzlerin auf dich im
großen und ganzen scheint mir das jetzt
auf den ersten blick sehr nah dran
geblieben zu sein an der
beschlussvorlage die wir bekommen haben
ich habe jetzt auch gerade in der
sekunde den fertigen beschluss bekommen
aber hatte noch keine zeit da genau im
detail rhein zu gucken wir haben ja eben
gehört was angela merkel vorgetragen hat
da war auf jeden fall mit drin dass die
hausärzte jetzt zwei wochen früher dran
kommen sie hat dann noch mal vorgetragen
mit welchen impfdosen das erreicht
werden soll denn das wurde vorher auch
schon war vorher so angedacht dass über
eine zusätzliche lieferung die aus einem
eu kontingent kommt an beyond impfstoff
auch hausärzte schon mal zusätzlich
beliefert werden sollten
da müsste ich nochmal rein gucken weil
ich habe gerade mal überschlagen die
bundeskanzlerin hat hier zahlen genannt
wie sich das verteilt zum einen geht das
an besonders betroffene grenzregionen um
eben die mutanten die möglicherweise
über frankreich oder tschechien
eingetragen werden können in schach zu
halten so zu sagen da ist die verteilung
so dass das saarland 80.000 zusätzliche
dosen bekommen soll rheinland pfalz
20.000 bayern und sachsen jeweils
100.000 thüringen 30.000 wenn ich jetzt
richtig gerechnet habe dann
unterscheidet sich das von den
ursprünglichen zahlen insofern als etwas
mehr in die grenzregionen ginge und
etwas weniger nämlich 30
sind weniger an hausarztpraxen aber das
muss man sich dann noch mal ganz genau
angucken nicht dass ich jetzt hier
falsch überschlagen habe es ist aber so
susanne zusätzliches kontingent soll in
grenzregionen gehen und an die hausärzte
bei den hausärzten eben damit es
möglichst schnell los geht direkt nach
ostern am fünften april und auch
interessant ist dass sich offensichtlich
die bayerische forderung durchgesetzt
hat die da in der beschlussvorlage drin
war das nämlich die hausärzte zwar
grundsätzlich sich an die priorisierung
halten sollten also zunächst mal die
besonders gefährdeten gruppen ansprechen
sollten aber auch die möglichkeit haben
dann flexibel zu sein
da ist jetzt noch nicht geklärt was das
genau heißt wie viel freiraum da
wirklich da ist aber das war auch schon
auffällig kann also die grenzregionen
auch vielleicht noch mal zur erläuterung
um eben auch da noch mal gegen die virus
mutationen besser gerüstet zu sein
die kanzlerin hat davon gesprochen dass
das infoangebot bis sommer aufrecht
erhalten bleiben soll also ihre
ankündigung dass es besonder für alle
ein solches angebot geben wird war das
eine mutige ankündigung oder wie schätzt
du das 1
es ist zumindest eine ankündigung auf
einer unsicheren basis wir haben hier
jetzt gesehen was mit astrazeneca
passiert ist wir wissen auch dass es bei
den lieferungen von impfstoff nie die
hundertprozentige sicherheit geben kann
weil schon durch kleinste veränderungen
in der lieferkette es zu engpässen
kommen kann
der astra zeneca impfstoff wird auch
obwohl er jetzt weiter vertieft werden
kann nicht in der ursprünglich
vorgesehenen anzahl zur verfügung stehen
dass man glaube ich zwei millionen dosen
die jetzt weniger erst mal ankommen in
der nächsten zeit sie war auch er hat
einen moment gezögert so habe ich das
wahrgenommen als sie gefragt worden ist
ob sie ob sie ihr versprechen halten
kann hat sich hat dann aber trotzdem
jahr gesagt und man kann nach der
sitzung heute auch davon ausgehen dass
sich alle sehr darum bemühen werden das
hinzubekommen
nicht weil angela merkel das gerne so
hätte sondern weil natürlich bund und
länder und insgesamt wir alle zusammen
ja auch tatsächlich
uns sehr wünschen dass das klappt also
man hat heute gesehen weniger bürokratie
für ärzte ist auch geplant
da hatte angela merkel so schön gesagt
zur deutschen gründlichkeit sollen mehr
flexibilität kommen
es stimmt ja dass wir uns oft sehr
schwer tun von von formularen und und
liebgewonnenen bürokratischen abläufen
abschied zu nehmen aber da soll sich
jetzt offensichtlich etwas tun damit es
für die hausärzte auch nicht zu
schwierig und zu umständlich wird damit
zu helfen beim impfen ja also vielleicht
leichter zögern bei der frage nach dem
sommer und dem versprechen mit den
impftermin aber schnell kam das ja
beziehungsweise das nein muss man sagen
meinem eindruck nach bei der frage ob
das ganze jetzt irgendwelche
konsequenzen für jens spahn hat die
vergangenen tage und wochen wo es also
doch kritik gegeben hat am management
des bundesgesundheitsministers aber auch
das vermutlich nicht überraschend das
kann ich jetzt nicht wirklich
beantworten weil da muss man hier die
technischen besonderheiten erläutert ich
bin ja zwischendurch auch immer schon
mal live im hauptprogramm
da war ich genau zu dem zeitpunkt live
19 uhr sendung das heißt die stelle habe
ich nicht gesehen aber was ich sagen
kann ist dass angela merkel natürlich
nicht aufgefallen ist in letzter zeit
damit dass die jens spahn öffentlich
kritisiert hat es war ja schon genug
dass sie dass sie an mehreren stellen
gesagt hat naja da stellen wir ihnen
jetzt mal hilfe zur seite
das wird übrigens im
bundesgesundheitsministerium anders
gesehen wenn man sich da umhört dann
heißt es na ja jede hilfe derzeit ist
ist ohnehin gerne genommen und und wenn
wir prozesse verbessern können dadurch
dass mehr leute eingebunden werden dann
ist das auch gut so
aber in der außenwahrnehmung ist das
natürlich ein rückschlag für den
gesundheitsminister wenn die kanzlerin
sagt das kriegt er offensichtlich nicht
alleine hin
ja das wäre ja auch kein gutes signal
jetzt im superwahljahr was die union
angeht ja momentan sowieso auch andere
baustellen hat werden fünf schon kurz
darüber gesprochen
auch da muss er das interesse eigentlich
sein dass das jetzt möglichst
reibungslos alles weiter verläuft ja gar
keine frage das gilt natürlich für alle
parteien insbesondere aber für die
regierungsparteien und ganz besonders
für cdu und csu denn die haben
momentan wirklich schwer zu kämpfen es
sind vor allem unionsminister unions
minister in der bundesregierung die
besonders kritisiert werden
der gesundheitsminister und der
wirtschaftsminister allen voran aber
auch anja karliczek weil ihr weil es
viel kritik an der schule misere in der
pandemie gibt da weist sie immer wieder
darauf hin dass sie nur begrenzte
möglichkeiten hat weil bildungspolitik
sache der länder ist aber es sind eben
unions minister und ministerinnen die
der in der kritik stehen und hinzu kommt
die masken affäre die natürlich extrem
negative auswirkungen hat auf das
vertrauen in cdu und csu
da versucht man jetzt relativ schnell
aufzuräumen und jede gute nachricht und
und jedes zeichen dafür das
krisen-management doch gelingen kann ist
natürlich jetzt sehr gerne gesehen
soweit also die einschätzungen dazu
jetzt würde mich aber noch interessieren
weil wir haben jetzt natürlich den
impfgipfel da ging es in erster linie ja
nur um das impfen in anführungszeichen
auch das natürlich ein ganz wichtiges
thema aber das nächste bund länder
treffen steht ja dann schon bevor und
auch da gab es eine kurze einlassung der
kanzlerin die doch glaubt die notbremse
jetzt ziehen zu müssen in welche
richtung wird sich das wohl entwickeln
ja das ist die große frage ob man da
eine einheitliche regelung finden kann
wo sich alle einig sind ist dass man
keine weiteren lockerungen beschließen
kann
die frage ist aber müsste man
tatsächlich das rad wieder zurückdrehen
darauf hatte sich die bund länder runde
ja beim letzten mal geeinigt und hat
rein geschrieben
ab einem incidents wert von 100 nach
nach zwei tagen glaube ich würden das
müsste ich jetzt noch mal nachschlagen
nachdem er nach mehreren langsam nachdem
mehrere tage der inzidenz wert von 100
überschritten ist fällt das feld die
entsprechende region oder das bundesland
automatisch zurück in den shutdown dem
jetzt alle schon so gut kennen aber es
ist nicht ganz genau definiert gewesen
ob das jetzt für ein ganzes bundesland
gilt oder eine region und das legen
momentan alles so ein bisschen
unterschiedlich für sich selbst aus dass
die kanzlerin sich da mehr
einheitlichkeit wünscht das ist bekannt
dass sie da auch immer vom bayerischen
ministerpräsidenten unterstützt worden
ist ist auch bekannt
aber wie das jetzt am montag ausgeht das
wage ich heute noch nicht zu beurteilen
weil die stimmen da eben wirklich sehr
sehr unterschiedlich sind und in ganz
unterschiedliche richtungen gehen es
gibt bundesländer die sagen wir müssen
den incidence wert ganz neu bewerten
wir können nicht nur dabei bleiben wir
müssen quasi ein neues system aufstellen
nachdem wir dann eben über schotter uns
entscheiden und andere die sagen
angesichts der infektionszahlen müssen
wir jetzt bei dem bleiben was wir einmal
beschlossen haben das wird noch viel
diskutiert werden morgen und übermorgen
in der vorbereitung auf die sitzung denn
da gibt es ja viele gespräche auch
zwischen den staatskanzleien der
bundesländer und dem bundeskanzleramt
und dem gesundheitsministerium also das
wird jetzt das ganze wochenende
ordentlich hin und her gehen damit sich
da irgend eine einigung abzeichnen kann
und auch dazu wird es dann wieder
informationen und einschätzungen von dir
und den kollegen aus berlin geben vielen
dank für den moment und einen schönen
abend ins hauptstadtstudio stellt der
manager war das für uns danke schön und
ich lese vielleicht gerade noch vor
claudia schoppmann schreibt uns über
youtube für eine impfung ist besser als
keine impfungen biontech moderner
astrazeneca sputnik wie johnson &
johnson egal ich will also auch nach
dieser woche gibt es offenbar leute die
sich eben sehr gerne impfen lassen
wollen und das kann man ja auch vor dem
hintergrund dessen was die experten
sagen durchaus verstehen
wir danken euch für euer interesse das
war der live stream für diesen abend der
relativ lange gedauert hat aber ich
denke wir haben auch einiges über das
virus wieder bzw auch die strategie der
bundesregierung erfahren und euch
hoffentlich auch näher bringen können
danke schön für das interesse für die
kommentare
einen schönen abend ein schönes
wochenende und bis demnächst